[Music]
if you keep saying it
i feel like we need to course correct
fast nope we have merch now
of course correct later is like
something babies say
yeah when they're pooping but you know
bob wop
very similar head of the times really
um we have a couple announcements before
we get to the j shetty interview jay
shetty's here
that's a big deal yeah that is a big
deal jay shetty's heart decay is the
number one best-selling book on the new
york times and he's on our podcast
remember when our podcast had a format
when it wasn't remember when it was an
after school special remember
and she was like we're the day guys it's
our word of the day
you guys ever heard the word caboose you
ever heard it
it's the back of a train use it in a
sentence
write me text me how you use the word
kabus like what the fuck are you doing
i think it was just a way for you to be
like i'm a writer have you guys ever
been um have you ever emoted immaculate
moments and you're like what
so i was gonna suggest that we bring
back the word of the day
but clearly that's just lames at all
so fucking lame what the fuck it was
dumb
invented you lily call me you we are
adults and you would call me and be like
okay the word of the day is stricken off
and you're like i'm like why you're like
i heard in a documentary and i'm like
use some contents clues figure it out on
your own you and these context clues
that's truly how i figure everything out
it's not even interesting okay so the
word of the day no one liked it and no
one told me i'm sure some loser out
there liked it but it's not
not the main fan base our main fan face
likes jokes and tds
titties yeah oh well then i i then drive
something for the fans today
i don't think that what well no i need i
i'm you know i want to share this on the
podcast i'm going to get vulnerable
i this past weekend yep saturday
sent the first photo of my boobs in a
bra
to a man that i've sent in literally
five years
of my boobs in a brawl i'm back in the
game so to speak
i'm back out there okay and i'm texting
with this guy who's in another city and
i was like you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna send a photo of my taste
i'm going to send a photo of my attitude
and i did and i forgot first of all i
forgot
how long it feels between the time you
send it and the time he responds
eternity
dude it feels like a lifetime's
everybody like in fetal position
in the corner know that he's standing by
before you send a picture of your
titties no
he's somewhere close to his phone oh
yeah because then you'll start noticing
why
this picture could've been better i
could have done this angle i could have
dude i started sending it to all my
friends like does this look crazy
are these uneven like why isn't he
responding like and they were like this
is harassment
this is we're calling hr my friendships
have an hr department
now that's that's what that's honestly
hollywood we're not that far away from
that dumb shit
but he basically it took like 10 minutes
for him to respond
and dude the little three dots came up
dot dot
i'm like standing there fucking like
drooling like what is he gonna say and
then the dots went away
yeah he's like i have nothing for this
bitch then roll back
you were wearing a bra right yes i was
wearing a bra now
a white bra bronzer we still find
lingerie sexy right it's not like
wearing a swimsuit at this point
look here's what i'll say i do think
lingerie
and und and swimsuits they're the same
but i don't i'm not i won't send
after a couple dates my nude
body that's a but i will i'm in my
lingerie shoot i'm not a
whore but you sent your picture do you
have a boner from thinking about me
naked
no can we stop talking about my genitals
on this podcast please
people love it who asked do you have a
boner
you just said that to my face what do we
call it is dippy
we don't call it anything what are you
doing
what do what's my best friend like this
like what do we call hard a hard-on a
hard-on i'm i'm telling you i'm getting
back in the game and i need
help caught a big raging cock
i think cock is awake i hate the word
cock i think this is a sexier word hate
cock and i hate pussy
dick is so stupid here's your dick leak
can i i'm trying to think yeah i need to
work on my dirty talk yeah cock is way
dirtier
let me see that it sounds like
uh i don't know i don't i don't like
it's too like a
it's called a dick or a cock there's no
other words for it
wiener a brogurt tube
oh gross okay we have to get back to my
boobs because i sent a picture of them
speaking of brogurt
i sent a picture of them and i didn't
realize till
after i sent it that i had
lotion because you know i like to lube
up my face there's a reason i look like
a newborn babe all the time
never not moisturizing and i actually
cake on moisturizer and i keep it on all
day
yeah you're a slug i look up you leave a
snail trail it's like
it's like i look like i have kabuki
makeup on at all times am i allowed to
say that
no am i canceled
and so i send the photo wait
10 minutes for the response then realize
i've sent him a photo of me
with the maboobs and i have a big glob
of lotion on the side of my chin
i don't even notice you have a chin in
that picture dude
i mean huh guys don't zoom in
on titty photos you don't think he was
zooming in not on your channel
he's trying to see how big your areolas
are dude
it's a glob of lotion it looks like calm
does he think
i was trying to send him a money shot
worst case scenario that's how he
pictured the photo anyways
so honestly you just saved some time
like i have fucking
lubriderm on my chin looks like
i mean it looks like i just finished a
sandwich a hoagie
i just deep throated a hoagie son yeah i
used
my love clam chowder oh
god how embarrassing i'm sure he didn't
hot hot hot hot hot
zoom in sloppy bitch yeah
side note though if you send that photo
to someone and they go evolution on your
face
that's cancelled i mean what do you
think i'm going to show you i'm not
going to show you guys the
topless photo obviously because i'm
classy i class it up
yeah you can you can google the other
network photo don't you think that's a
good photo that's a great photo oh that
bro
that is fully on a bra photo that's a
nude photograph what
i know you think that because you have
mesh over your nipple that it's not nude
i can i can see your boob
that you're nude in that picture no i'm
not a mermaid you're a nude
that is at best that's um
spaghetti noodles you wrapped around
yourself do i am i a slut
no i don't believe in that but if you
did would i be
no was this too much because i talked to
esther and annie
um who no one should ever take any
advice from and they told me
there was another one that i was going
to stand where i was like covering my
boobs with no bra and they were like
that is
way too sexy do not say they're both
female comedians though you know female
comedians are like
averse to being sexy because of all the
stigmas that go along with it i know but
i'm just
i just they were i think for me because
i'm a little bit older we used to go
a little harder in my day now you gotta
sort of like you gotta guys
and you know what it is you know what i
remember the body chains you were going
rough
but what before i was successful i could
be more sexually aggressive
but now that i people see me as dominant
in alpha i have to be like
like in relationships or in sexual
situations i have to be like
what like i have to be a little like
yeah do you know what i'm saying well
you know that then because that's
white lace it's bro even though we can
see through it
you like like a maiden like a spring
just came the first blood
but i have to for guys to feel like
they're dominant
over me i have to like be like like
handicapped i have to be like
i need to get like a cast
like your gypsy robe blanchard you're
just like you're just a make-a-wish
patient you're like i wish for that dick
please like that's you it's a good thing
you're like meet me in a motel i'm gonna
start carrying out a fake cast like ted
bundy did that's how we got
girls she's gonna have an iv drip
i just mean like i i what they made me
realize is you
you it has to be more if we did word of
the day we'd have some adjectives for
this but like impish and sweet and
impish i hate the sexiest word i've ever
heard i hate the word girly because
that's
it just i hate that shit but like i have
to be like a little innocent little bow
peep like
yeah you have to be a maiden
you have to be someone who's like please
sir only your dick can save me now
please
i can't carry my hefty boobs sir please
carry them for me
they feel me like that's what you have
to be it's very stupid
i'm just saying like i i think white
lingerie
and less aggressive like i sent a photo
that was too aggressive that's what i'm
trying to get to
i was too aggressive that thought is
pretty aggressive
fuck it is aggressive but i don't think
that i mean
you think i showed my nipple i shouldn't
show my nipple
damn it i think you want that though i
think that you
sending a picture like that if you want
a guy who's gonna be okay with you being
aggressive it's gonna be more like
it's gonna match that i don't know i
don't know
human nature doesn't really work that
way but thank you thank you so much well
that worked out great
except for wait how did he respond oh my
god we haven't even said how he
responded yeah so we don't know how it
worked out actually here's what
you the the fans will decide do i say
viewers or listeners
friends fans that sounds that's
embarrassing that sounds like
self-aggrandizing
yeah um i realize there is no
good way for a man to respond to a nudie
there's nothing you can say that's going
to get me out of my insecurity spiral
once i've sent it
except maybe the emoji where the head is
blown off
oh the blow yeah that one like three of
those the water squirts that's a good
one
nope nope that's a good one no it's not
yeah that come
yeah no hell yeah yeah yeah that's a
great one here yeah
the blow up brain emoji i think the
squirts are good the drool face emoji it
looks like it
you know i don't know emojis in general
though i don't i don't
know well i like to talk in
hieroglyphics
just the word what's good hot
no it's not it's too too too curt
hot period yeah no no periods this guy
wrote back
oh good okay my producer just held up
the red emoji face with the teardrop
that's good hmm i like that but then
it's like i'm picturing you going into
your most used emojis like do you use
that emoji a lot then now i don't feel
special
are you like scrolling and looking for
it he wrote back this are you ready
wow period period
wow period wow period i don't know if i
would like that
it's just all it's a it's a workshop
test it's open for interpretation is it
like
wow or it's like wow well either way i'd
be like if you said wow i'm going to say
a while back you're like
wow wow wow you sure
i think i wrote that back i wrote you
sure question mark like that's your
response
and then i got really combative because
i was so insecure always you're so
vulnerable and also
it's actually i was in such a spiral
taking nude photos of myself which by
the way to send one
photo of myself in a bra i took truly 70
photos my photo album looks like an only
fans account right yeah i think that
women
and probably bottoms put a lot of work
into
sending nude photos as opposed to but
here's what else i got super distracted
too because i was taking
photos of myself and then i real i
started noticing like new moles and i
was like wait a second that's a new mole
and then i'm like shit i need to send
this to my dermatologist that's what
happens when you take nudies as you get
older you're like wait a second
is that mole changing that's good you're
just casting a wider net
what are they what are the what are the
things size
color shape shape is that diamond rings
or moles like you remember
i think the toddler cut carrot cancer
everyone has seen a nude picture right
of course
everyone has it's the most vulnerable
thing you can do yeah because you've put
on this time and now you're also like
it's like the ultimate rejection too
because now you think this picture is
good
do are we putting our face in our nudes
i think that
you probably shouldn't is putting your
face in your nudes like using a
disc man at this point am i like out am
i such an idiot
they're not fun to take or send i gotta
be honest with you
i get anxious i get stressed out i get
worried because i
i i like to see this is why i'm a comic
i like to see someone's
involuntary instantaneous reaction
otherwise i don't believe them it's like
you know what it is
because then when someone's like oh my
god you look amazing it's like oh what
if he's just doing that thing that i do
when i see an ugly baby
you know how you feel like so
overcompensate you have to like get
square the baby's amazing
so cute you know what i mean you know
when you like or when you see any woman
in hollywood that's how they all react
to each other
oh my god oh my god just starting slice
life's like
fire fire far far far you're like we're
45 stops what are you talking about
do you like receiving nude pictures nope
not from a man absolutely not nope
never under no circumstances really i
would like a copy of your credit report
please
why do you not like it i think it's this
is
sexist i'm sexist biology sexist sorry
i'm
i'm gonna say it i know what you're
gonna say it's unattractive
it's just it's just not it looks um
it's just oh god i'm trying to be pc
here
it's bitch i don't know it's like
you're trying to get my approval or my
validation like what is it
okay but is that all you mean you want
me to like what the hell are you
describing are you just trying to think
you're hot don't send me a nude photo
just don't respond to my texts
yeah i'm damaged i'm just saying like
it's just too
thirsty like it's too like look at me
i'm the shit like when guys know they're
hot it's just not as attractive but are
you
talking about like full body nudes like
where they're taking in a mirror or do
you mean like just a dick pic like
picturing a guy like putting
their phone in selfie mode it's just
like on a track no
okay yeah i'm kind of do you like just a
dick pic a picture of a p no
nope so you're saying that just for him
and you want nothing in return
the nude pictures i used to send
they're out of style yeah that was very
good
you think i did okay i think that was
really in style i think the only thing
you could do is um
you know maybe set up a self-timer and
move further back that feels a little
like that is what you're doing though
you're posing for a photo i think you
need to see your arms in the photo i
think
well otherwise he's going to be like who
took that he don't know about
self-timers or they don't
i would if someone sent me a photo of
them on self-timer i would think someone
else took it
when you take a self-timer photo for a
man i have never done that i think that
puts more
like that to me is sexier than you're
like don't like tick tock password you
know i don't know how to use a
self-timer
you have all people but that's just like
saying like this is for you i set it up
i did this just for you
yeah that's hot can you run this podcast
more smoothly please
yeah i'll work on it um so you know some
restaurants around the world are using
dining bubbles
did you know that this is the part where
we do news in case you guys didn't know
this is
news from around this time i mean
look you didn't like when i organized
things because we did vocab words so
let's see
let's see how it goes when you run it
shit technically this was still your
idea
um yeah some restaurants are using
dining bubbles you're putting people in
bubbles to eat their meals why benton
for coverage yeah for safety it's like a
it's like a being in a pod
it's honestly like being in a ziploc bag
you know how gross that would be
especially with your if you're with your
friend that orders like salmon feta
jalapeno
poppers and you're just sitting in a
ziploc bag of like heat and stench
doesn't that sound gross i mean like
just when first dates couldn't get more
awkward
now if you're in a giant condom with
your person yeah i mean you're gonna
refer
let's put them in a snow globe see how
that works out
that's kind of amazing actually like
that's really what you're all doing
although i do like the idea of me being
physically away from people
but still having the ability to see and
judge them like that
well here's the thing with me when i go
out to restaurants i'm the person that
wants to look at other people's meals
and ask them how it is
i'm that bitch like how are the chicken
fingers are they good
are they good oh that's good i i do that
it is
that's me also something you should
about whitney when when he goes into any
restaurant any place where there is food
she does not look at the menu she just
starts naming food she likes she's just
like do you have quiches
and they're like like this is an auto
parts it's like there's like three oreo
cookies and some sodas
the amount of times that you went in a
place and asked for a quiche is
shocking to me i mean and then we'll
argue
why you should get keisha's here are you
seeing her all the time i'm also the
person that goes into the store i was
laughing with chrissy teigen about this
yesterday
name drop uh i'm the customer that goes
into a store because i was telling her
about your joke
about how when you're working in retail
people walk up to you and oh yeah
ask if it's the price is this the price
is this the price and then
she goes yeah also when she worked in a
boutique she was like people always ask
if
there's more in the back like they think
there's so much in the back oh my god
i'm the person was like do you have
another size in the back do you have
more of these in the back
you know what's in the back employees
crying and eating microwave food that's
literally what's going on in the back of
that room all stock rooms
there's just sara lee microwavable
lunches
and then one person on a phone like cry
it is not there's nothing back there for
you it's a
sad a stockroom of a of a store is the
saddest place on earth
i i think if the stockroom is like like
the north pole
i think there's like elves and santa and
little wooden hammers i feel like
they're just like
it's like narnia of just like more
everyone does clothes
but then why and they get mad they'll be
like oh is there not anything back there
is there not so so when they go back
what takes them so long though like if
you go to bloomingdale's you're like
it's a break
you've now told me to go to the bank
they pretend they're like
looking through this labyrinth of shoe
sizes i used to sit in the back when i
worked at sephora i would sit in the
back
and i would text you to try to get dates
to go on tour
that's all those techniques you got
before you knew me that's what i was
doing checking the back so someone go
can you check in the back and
i'd be like i sure will i would eat i
would make food i would do anything if
it said check them back and then you
come in the bag go
sorry i looked everywhere yeah cause i
already told you we didn't have it so if
you want me to go on this wild goose
chase you can wait a minute
because when i come back we're still not
gonna have it if we had it why would i
not want to sell it to you that's my
whole job
why would i not want to give you the
product
i would do anything to make people can
you check me faster but can you check
the back yeah i'd be like absolutely and
then i would just say gone first
feel like there's more in the back and
you're lying to me i mean i would stay
gone for
20 30 minutes yeah and i'm like oh he's
really looking and i'd be like i looked
everywhere i'm so sorry i called some
other i called other stores for you
is that not real you can do that but i
fully lie
i used to people would ask me if
somebody had a bad attitude can you
check another store i would fully just
get a computer and just start clicking
the keys they can't see the computer
and i'd be like oh my god it's sold out
everywhere can't even check that way you
have to call
being rude to retail employees does not
benefit you
nobody cares if you come back nobody
cares if you shop there anymore
nobody cares you have no ownership in
the company yeah those people are
working minimum wage there all day long
they don't give a shit if you ever come
back or if you get a lipstick or a
couch or a plant this podcast went off
the rails
that's good information people don't
know yeah no i agree i agree
what else is going on in the news benton
or the zeitgeist if you will
oh man zeitgeist do you know what that
means is that guys yeah like the overall
inner like you know like everywhere
like an overall being of things i'm not
stupid i went to college
i know i'm just saying if we had word of
the day maybe you would be able to
define that more clearly but we
don't the zeitgeist is like you exist
within it it's a thing that people it's
like a collective conscious we all know
yeah that's actually
true yeah okay we're gonna edit that out
we're gonna edit out you knowing that so
much
uh mass yeah people are wearing them did
you hear okay
no here's the thing okay okay okay so i
went out into the world recently finally
since we're going on tour which we
haven't told anyone about the
new tickets on sale because we're too
busy talking about my tits um
people think wearing masks around their
chin is wearing a mask
and look i i david agus was on the
podcast
i i believe in distancing i believe in
masks i i don't think you should wear a
mask if
you're alone in your car you fucking
dorks
uh i'm not super extreme about it
but don't wear a mask around people and
then
put it right like under your chin
like this and then think it's doing
anything
it's like a guy when they um get a
magnum condom
and they don't need it that's all it
makes me think about don't it looks
when you have a saggy ass just take it
out just don't wear it then just don't
because now i have to look at this ball
sack on your face you have ball sack
mask sack also some people are just
wearing it just under their nose
that's like putting on pants and then
pulling your dick out of the zipper hole
and just being like that's good enough
it's just like that's where all the
gross stuff comes out of
i don't know it's so interesting to me
that we all just wear masks now
remember when that was weird if you said
we're just all leather face now
like we're all just in a kinky sex game
all the time yeah
like now what am i gonna do when i wanna
have sexy sex
i have to not wear a mask you have to
look at my face
when you want to have sexy sex i think
that'll work out great i don't know
what that had to do with the man also
can i can i one more thing about the
mask i'm noticing just as this is
becoming normal
we need to watch with the fun masks i
feel like the fun masks have gotten a
little out we're still in a pandemic
guys people are still
crossing over people are still uh
dying in the streets and people just
have like the fucking i walk through the
grocery stores everyone's got a mask
it's like toy story
yeah and like it's always so and here's
the thing and there's designers
you gotta watch the fun masks because
you never know when you're getting an
altercation and you're gonna need
someone to take you seriously
the other day i had like this guy cut me
off in the 405 and i was like fucking
asshole and he looked over
did not at all look scared of me and i
realized i had
my mask on it was cat whiskers upside
down
totally yeah it's just you yelling at a
man with a live laugh love mask on think
what the fuck
that said please buy our funny masks
please buy them what about designers
making like
900 face masks well that's just that's
that's you know what that we call that
capitalism a fucking racket
that's a racket that's chicanery a word
from the pod
from about seven months ago who
remembered
me chicken right chicanery there
probably was not even a word remember it
was it was a word of the week of where
to the whatever pod we did
right we have to move on this has gone
on too long we've been with this is a
rambling podcast and i'm going to try to
not edit the podcast
i think that people will really enjoy
this you think
really yeah because i have faith in me
and you
i mean there's no word of the day nobody
learned any vocab but okay i think they
learned a lot of vocabs
do we should we bring anything back that
we used to do um i mean fears and
resentments people seem to like from
what i could gather
really yeah i think people like it those
are our nicknames
i think that i think they liked it
because it was like we did this like
really
fun goofy kind of segment then at the
end we told like personal
like nice things okay and it made us you
know honorable and likable
they were like oh they're not clowns got
it yeah i was like i'm surprised
okay um uh i could talk to you all day
benton
um but we need to talk about also the
fucking tour the tour which happens
what is it this week we're gonna be in
escondido
uh what day friday the october 2nd
i have no idea what the friday october
2nd you are correct i didn't do an hour
of stand up somehow denver i think we're
sold out of all those shows
cape cod october 15th i don't think i'm
famous in cape cod
i don't know what is i don't lobsters
i truly don't i tried to google cape cod
as he was around there and i was like i
think it's
i mean whatever cape cod i'm coming
there i think it's a vacation
destination
for people whose grandparents had slaves
i don't know ghost hunters yeah we're
putting it on the map i don't know but
cape cod we're going to be there
on october 15th we're going to be at a
drive-in it's going to be outside
so come on let's go i my self-esteem
i don't want to go play for 12 cars it's
just going to hurt my feelings
uh or you know what don't you know what
how about this don't buy tickets
i could use no no i could i could use
some humbling right about now maybe it'd
be good for me
all the phones start ringing it's just
all your managers like what the fuck are
you doing my publicist
uh what else uh ocean port new jersey
i'm gonna be there october 18th we're
doing two shows
seven and nine thirty it's gonna be cold
i can't wait november seventh and eighth
right we're gonna be at the midway are
we gonna be there two nights i don't
think that i don't think the
second night's on my website uh whitney
coming
is it dot com or dot gov i can never
remember.gov
uh text me 818-239-7527 i've been
sending out birthday messages
to people every day yesterday i fucked
up the date and people got very mad at
me i was like hey guys happy birthday
september 22nd
everyone or whatever the fuck day was
and i got it wrong and they're like it's
the 24th
i was like jesus christ that was a
re-gift
i know i was like god damn they got
really upset so i had to re-record it
but i am sending out birthday messages
every day and updates on shows and such
so go to the website you know what to do
ben and i are both wearing
new merch new merch not yet available
though should be october 8th
october 8th we're having a new merch
merch launch but for now we've got masks
and hoodies
available on the site thanks for asking
we do
we have a and the new stuff is going
over really well way down the night
it's a good song maybe wait a second oh
my god do i secretly want to sing
like vin diesel i think everyone's
secretly wants to sing
really yes i don't i don't know karaoke
i'm i don't think karaoke's fun or fun
i'm like that bitch okay why why you
said to me
i'm not the person that's like but i
secretly just want to be a singer papa
i have i'll pull up a message i have a
text from you where you text me and you
said
should we do a segment on the podcast
where i sing because sometimes i think i
can
i have a message that says that you said
sometimes i think i can
and i said if you want to no it's a it's
a written one i have to find it
okay you really sent it to me i have
coffee coming out of my nose
okay i think should we do a segment
called can whitney sing because
sometimes i think i can what times
name them i'm gonna puke oh my god that
was so funny okay i think
i think i think
what i was trying to say is like i
sometimes think i can sing so i feel
like we should do a segment where people
let me know if i can
like i think i could be a good singer
but i'm not sure if i'm good enough
you're a walking contradiction
i'm just gonna say i'm not that bitch
who does karaoke i'm not that bitch
who's saying
i don't know i don't do karaoke because
i don't like watching people cover
ruin a good song i'm like i'd rather
just hear the original but you forcing
people to listen to you saying
it with people like wow dang i'm just
like get into rehab
you're a mess like i just for me when
people do karaoke it's always just like
all the people i need to do
interventions on in my life i'm like oh
god
um so it's like up stresses me out
because i feel like when you do karaoke
that's when you find out which of your
friends are alcoholics do you like doing
duets
no i put your picture away
sat down and cried today
i can't look at you while i'm lying
next to her i love that song
me too even though it's kid rock it's
such a bummer that he's like queuing on
he's only ruining nashville but that's
fine um what is his deal
his his uh did he do an american woman
cover that was actually really sexy i
used to think he was sexy
you have a little booger that's because
you made me spit out of my nose i'm
sorry that i'm so
funny um all right this is a wild open
this might be our most wild open
yeah which whitney will not like but i
think you will enjoy it i know i'm gonna
like have a complete panic attack when
we wrap it
like we need to edit everything let's
just leave it let's see if i cannot edit
this
let's see what the fans think well
they'll never know because
you get it first no i'm not out of this
but we need to get to j
shetty j shetty he's brilliant the fact
that we got him is a very big deal
i have noticed though on twitter
sometimes when when someone is on the
podcast they'll tweet like hillary duff
at 57 minutes in they'll they'll tweet
out the time codes yeah because they
don't want to hear them when the
celebrity starts
um so j shetty you're going to get so
much out of this i love you guys thank
you
bye babe
when i'm dehydrated i'm a mess i'm a
wreck
i feel i feel like a dried apricot a
little raisin
but i'm saying everyone's like how do
you get your skin to be so good i'm
telling you i just like
pound like this um
it's called hydrant and i put it in my
water because we all know i hate the
taste of water i'm sorry i'm mikey
canceled for that hot take water's gross
yeah and this makes you drink a lot of
water with this but i will not drink
water
that's just regular it just tastes like
spit to me am i allowed to say any of
this i mean honestly you like this so
much that you're
i've caught you trying to put it in
coffees and stuff and i'm like that's
for water
i think you're allowed to do that i feel
like you can flavor coffee with it but
the brand has not said that i can say
that publicly but i
you can mix it with anything i put like
in smoothies okay so basically it's this
it's like
it's like these little packets that have
um
it's like a little powder that you mix
they have like electrolytes
as your four essential electrolytes
sodium potassium magnesium and zinc
so this you just open the packet you
just mix it in that's it i also
when i um work out i'll just put it in
the water bottle and then just shake it
and then it's
delicious yeah and if you're not crazy
one of them has caffeine also
so you don't have to make it with coffee
that's what i was going to say hydrant
is backed by research it's just not it's
not some bullshit just
sugar crap powder trash it's loved by
pro athletes top performers celebrities
and has
thousands of five star reviews it's made
with real fruit juice powder
that's so it's no it's not like garbage
trash toxic chemicals
um what's your favorite flavor mine is
iced tea that's my favorite flavor and
you know it oh my god you're obsessed
with me
it's my favorite it's very southern my
body doesn't even recognize water unless
in the form of iced tea
sweet tea yeah but it's not too it's not
it's not sugary
here's what i like about i think a lot
of these like crappy
fake sports drinky hot like they they're
just sugar
this is like it doesn't leave little
like fuzzy
film sweaters on your teeth
gross real fruit juice powder delicious
refreshing variety of flavors
ooh new keto friendly lemonade i haven't
had that one yet oh with only two grams
of carbs oh
yeah yeah that one pink grapefruit no
added sugar
uh i would like to do the keto friendly
lemonade and mix it with the iced tea
ah yeah you want to ruin the whole keto
part
okay yes but that's like an arnold
palmer a hydrant orange
yeah try to say that let's double the
hydration try to say hydrant honorable
palmer
hydrant arnold palmer hydrant arnold
say it again hydrant arnold palmer
palmer
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners to save 25
of your first order go to
drinkhydrant.com whitney to enter our
promo code whitney at checkout
that's d-r-i-n-k-h-y-d-r-a-n-t
d-r-a-n-t.com
whitney and enter promo code whitney for
25 off your first order
drink hydrant.com whitney and enter
promo code whitney to save 25
and we thank you for sponsoring the
podcast hydrant where water meets
wellness and you can put it in your
purse
hey benton donkey shane what is a donka
i don't know you know what dog is in
german ready
hang on i think i know hund
what oh hund
no that's scary i want to have sex with
you hon style
what you are on one i'm on one today
hello
hello hello
we're trying to learn language what's
cat in german
what's smile what's dutch i wanna hear
dutch
i'm not on that one right now oh okay
that's not what we're doing benton
i looked up german words because i want
to learn german okay
you know what yes is well with babble
you can learn all kinds of new languages
hold on
yeah yeah yeah you can yeah
wait cheers that's goodbye
juice juice
[Music]
hello no this isn't about accents so
benton
likes to do accents and he likes to
think he's worldly doesn't count
first of all it's about languages tell
us about babel how can you be more
worldly
and more attractive more learning a new
language we have a lot of time right now
it's easy to start having conversations
uh babble uses well you're really
folding this in nathan no i'm not i'm
being organic
petting the dog and maybe bring your
charisma to this you're so jealous this
dog likes me
um it's like sad honestly it's actually
true like really upset
always goes to you babble babble
what is babel babel is a wonderful um
place where you can learn a website a
place what's the website and an app so i
don't know what to say
it's like a store what's a website and
apps you can stream it across all of
your services
basically it gets you speaking a new
language within
weeks with daily 15 to 10 minute
sessions
you're really phoning this in babel
teaches real life conversations
10 to 15 minute sessions yeah you're not
learning words and phrases out of
context you're learning through
interactive dialogue
also babble listen how they say you can
learn quicker
okay if you actually have conversations
also i get over after 15 minutes i stop
my brain shuts off like i like that it's
not these like long
boring lessons that take hours 15
minutes every day which is
reasonable and i also love that it has
speech recognition technology because it
helps you produce
improve improve your pronunciation and
accent which
can you pronounce this cuckoo banana ass
voice that's helpful
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german
good job
right now babel is offering our
listeners three months free with a
purchase of a three month subscription
that's dope right now hang on right now
we need benton to get babel for england
that's so
you guys have england do you teach
english to people that already think
they speak english right now babel is
offering our listeners three months free
with a purchase of a three-month
subscription with promo code good for
you
go to babel.com and use promo code good
for you
on your three month subscription that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
promo code good for you babel language
for life
okay hey shetty finally you're here
i'm so happy to be here thank you
whitney i'm grateful to be here i
am uh am going to say something that
you're
might want to make me cut um i
cannot believe i before we got on camera
i was like
i'm going to talk some shit with jay
shetty i was like so what do you think
of this guy
wouldn't talk shit with me this guy
walks the walk
actually lives uh uh by the word
of his now best-selling book i tried to
talk shit with him about someone he's
like no that guy's a really nice guy i
really like him
i wanted to talk some shit i wanted to
gossip
i i was just telling you the truth maybe
if you asked me about someone else i
would have said something else
okay afterwards we'll talk some shit
okay okay but it was just so evolved and
they're just so like oh that's the
person i want to be because i am so
addicted to talking shit and gossiping
it gives me that little hit of
superiority that little hint of
adrenaline
and i just wanted to talk some shit with
you and you wouldn't do it i was like
fuck he meant every word of this book i
tried
i tried we we literally used to have to
write well first of all i want to say
this so since i've been walking in
i have not stopped laughing which is
which is good which is great
but i've been you know we were trained
to every time our mind wanted to gossip
we'd literally have to like keep a tally
of it and then you would count
on a monday how many times you gossiped
and then on tuesday you'd use your
competitive energy to
do it less and then on wednesday do a
lesson then on sunday
you'd like binge gossip again and catch
up with all the mess
and then monday you try all over again
so it's tricky and i think it was
you walked in and i think i had a little
bit of insecurity
because you're so you're obviously
you're
like i don't have to tell you who jay is
you guys but you are um
when i feel like someone is like super
evolved
and i'm serious i feel like they see my
flaws
i do i feel like you know some shit i
can't manipulate you i can't beguile you
i can't outsmart you i can't out like
uh wisdom you and i
i i found myself like a little
uncomfortable so but i feel like i'm
back
well i was actually really taken by your
wonderful energy when i walked in so i
kind of just felt embraced and loved and
we couldn't give each other a real
embrace so
i just felt very welcomed and and
actually it should be the opposite that
if someone was
and i don't like making anyone feel that
way but if someone's actually involved
they should not judge you
or feel anything i should if you're
interviewing the most flawed right now i
felt this pressure to be like don't be
an asshole around this guy don't be
petulant don't be an idiot like be
gracious be grateful
you know like you're in the presence of
a monk like should i mean like
exactly pull it together so you've been
doing so many interviews
your book is is it the number one
best-selling book
yeah it was it's it's been amazing it's
been really incredible i
i'm totally humbled and grateful it's my
first one so okay so that's a big deal
you've been doing so many interviews i
do not want this to be a carbon copy of
every other interview
you've been doing so if you find
yourself repeating yourself please
shut up and let's talk about something
else you know what that makes me happy
because
my whole goal with every interview i did
was trying not to say and i've realized
that when
the incredible hosts guide me in the
direction they want to go in
then i'm willing to go with you so you
take me yeah again where you want to go
oh yeah we're going to go to some really
sticky areas and your publicist is going
to have a fucking heart attack i cannot
wait
so i really the thing i really want to
uh start with to frame this conversation
with you
is that so much of what you talk about
is about compassion and kindness
and service and on this podcast all of
you that know me know that
i am in recovery for codependence and a
big part of codependence
is you give too much of yourself you
become a doormat you have an
overdeveloped sense of responsibility
you martyr yourself for people
you know in codependence we do the three
m's marto
martyr micromanage and mother we rescue
people we self deprive
we give too much right codependence
breeds resentment
perfectionism we're the people that cook
a full meal
for our whole family but don't eat
anything and at the end we're eating
scraps over the
kitchen sink right so we are um
uh too nice sometimes and so as i was
reading your book i found myself going i
hope in this conversation
we can sort of talk about how to tell
when your compassion and love
and forgiveness and kindness which you
talk about so elegantly in your book
how we can develop the skill to
delineate
when it's codependence and when it's
thinking like a monk
i love that i'm totally with you on that
and that's such an
important point because i think that's
the difference that i think a lot of
these words now have become buzzwords
yes
and they fly around and because of that
we have a really
beginners understanding of these deep
essential qualities and values and so we
practice them at beginners level
and at that level they're still based on
wanting validation they're still based
on
wanting to fit in they're still based on
wanting to
be a part of being dependent or being
codependent yeah they're not coming from
a place
of internal purification and greatness
so
so i i'm totally with you on that and
i'm about motives it's really about
motives like
if you find yourself and if someone were
to ask me like you know because
i love that you talk about service in
this book it's such a big part of
i think what is going to fix everything
that's broken in our societies should be
able to um give and i think people don't
understand that giving is actually
selfish
you know i feel like i'm saying this in
a way that's grosser which is why my
book probably wasn't
the number one bestseller um and his was
because i say
i sound like a psychopath when i talk
about this shit which is like
when you give to others it's selfish you
benefit when you give so it's like
everybody wins absolutely it's like
forgiveness we forgive others not
because they deserve forgiveness but
because we deserve peace forgiveness is
selfish
absolutely but the intention with which
we give defines how deeply we feel it so
let's let's take for example two people
who want a given charity this year one
person wants to give it because they
really believe that the kids
deserve more food and better shelter and
better support the other person gives
because
they think it would be a good pr story
or they think that it would look good
for them to give a bit of activity
correct there you go so you've got two
people they let's say they both give a
million dollars each yeah
it's obvious who's gonna feel more joy
now bear in mind the kids benefit off
the money either way
but the person giving only receives joy
when they did it with the intention of
actually serving
yes and that's the missing link around
giving because giving isn't just the act
of
time money it's the act of energy right
presence and intention and also just
taking your mind off yourself i mean in
12-step programs the reason we do
service like honestly is to take the
focus off
yourself because the more we and it's
tricky and i find myself struggling with
the balance of this like
self-help self-love and self-self
self-social self
and when it becomes selfish and when it
self
lists and you know my brain i just get
so turned around in
self-care all i do is think about myself
and take care of myself and myself and
it's just
me me me me ultimately yeah and when
does
self-care become selfish and you do a
really good job
i think uh for anyone that is confused
um laying it out in a way that it's not
like
and also for people that non-hollywood
people the people
that are buying your book that we're
actually you know talking to
uh and not amongst like who they're like
i have three jobs
all i do is serve yeah yeah i have four
kids exactly
i actually need to do less service i
actually need to be less compassionate
and take care of myself
like finding that balance yeah
absolutely and that's what i loved about
the monk path that i chose
that the morning was all about the self
yeah and then rest of the day was about
service
and that gives you a really good
blueprint around how that works in the
sense of
if you've not done something for
yourself every day yeah
if you've not taken your time to invest
in yourself every day and that isn't
just a
you know it's it comes so much from
understanding yourself
and understanding yourself comes from
the place of knowing yourself and
getting
to know yourself and most of us spend so
much time co-dependency trying to get to
know someone else and what their needs
are
anticipate their needs and then
shape-shift so that i can be what i
think you want
to totally evolve yeah evolve and
transmorph
into this person that will be the best
for them but what about if you did that
for yourself
to start with and so most of us don't
even know what we want to eat for dinner
on a given day or like
what our favorite movies are we struggle
we sit there for like hours trying to
figure out what to watch
because we haven't really got to know
ourselves and so to me getting to know
yourself is very basic
after you eat a meal ask yourself did i
enjoy that what did i like about it
did i feel great 24 hours after reading
it after watching a movie
what did i like about it why did i enjoy
it those basic questions
will give you a much deeper
understanding of yourself god it's so
important jay i can't believe
like it took me so long i just turned
38. you're
september 6th september 4th i know uh
beyonce and many others
virgo season um because i can't believe
how much of my life i have spent doing
things that i didn't even really want to
do and that i didn't
i didn't even know someone would ask me
to go for a hike and i'd be like sure
like
i just thought friendships felt
obligatory i just felt they kind of felt
like work i just felt like you kind of
had to agree with things that you didn't
want to agree with i just felt like you
kind of had to laugh at jokes that
weren't funny like i just thought that's
what friendship was
yeah i just thought that was i thought
you just faked orgasms like i did not
like
you know and reading this book it really
made me stop and go like okay i just
hang out with that person
did it fill me up do i feel depleted by
that person
when they text me do i get a pit in my
stomach am i excited to respond
or do i can i just respond whenever i
want
because i had all these friendships that
were like oh god she texts me i need to
text her back girl she'll be mad that
we're all about keeping score
and then we're all about you know
recreating my childhood circumstance of
a borderline personality narcissist
mother and you
and i think so few of us just stop and
go
did i enjoy that meal yeah do i even
like
these movies do i even like this person
that i'm hanging out with every day
yeah and it all comes from confirmation
bias so we have this safety
mechanism of it's more comfortable for
the mind
to feel we agree than create a moment of
conflict
so the mind will continuously confirm
and surround ourselves with people that
confirm
our biases or we confirm theirs for the
feeling of com comfort
so we feel better when it's like you
tell me you like that blood orange
energy drink or the pomegranate
pomegranate one
cancer smoothie okay my highball energy
drink yes
yeah so for me to feel like we fit in
and we're going to have
we're going to get along and we're going
to have a friendship for a long time
yeah i would feel like if i confirmed
that bias i've not tried it before right
then i would feel like i fit in with you
and that's kind of how we were trained
this is
wired to kind of for harmony correct
we're wired for harmony but we look to
harmonize over the wrong thing
we harm and then what happens this isn't
our case but then you say you like this
and i'm like great and then i like
and now you just made a friend that you
don't want yeah totally and now every
time i come here you give me this drink
yes
now you have cancer it's sort of like
it's dishonest and i think that
that served us really well in tribal
times when we needed safety from the
tribes before alarm systems and locks on
doors we had to kiss everybody's ass
because we needed safety from everyone
right
but now these are these like obsolete
tools
that are frankly liabilities like we're
i
we're we're kind of the to me i see an
epidemic of just being too nice
creating harmony with toxic people does
not benefit you no and over
over dishonest things i think that's
really important that you can connect
and and also when you're looking at a
thing or an object or a like or a
dislike to connect yeah it's a pretty
uh it's pretty shallow ground to connect
on because you may change your mind
about that drink tomorrow yeah and now
we're talking about drinks but you may
change your mind on a hobby you may
change your mind on an interest you may
change your mind on an activity but
usually people stay pretty grounded to
values and qualities and that's kind of
this confirmation bias has just created
so many issues because we also go around
and look for people
who confirm our biases so then we get
into this
bubble and this cloud of thinking that
we can't break and that we can't you
know expose to so
it's so interesting and it's and i think
we have to have compassion for ourselves
in it as well you know like i
when someone sees someone else in the
same like sports jersey like if you're a
lakers fan and then you see someone
wearing a shirt you're like hey dude
it's like you don't know that guy
that guy could be a nazi like you but
you've just you know it's this like
confirmation bias of we like something
similar let's make harmony you know
there's something so pure and impish and
sweet and innocent about that yeah you
know people right now are at this time
where they're like
humans suck and humans are stupid and
like there's something kind of
beautiful about that we're willing to
accept someone based on
their colors on their shirts yeah and
well
and and if we really extend that we
should want to extend ourselves to
everyone yes because we all you know
what's that famous statement like we all
bleed the same air and bleed the same
blood and breathe the same man bleed the
same blood
and it's like you know at that core we
all know that we're the same
or have an essential sameness but that's
what we miss so we recognize the same
jersey or we recognize the same country
or the same city
yeah but then we don't recognize the
essential sameness
yeah which is the equal vision that
monks would speak about is like that's
real
equal vision is that realize we all wear
the same jersey
yeah yeah it's so interesting like i'm
i'm really
um getting into terror management theory
as well which is like
that you know basically humans are the
only species we know we're going to die
so we have with the we the anticipation
of knowing
you know we're basically just trash bags
full of blood that could die at any
moment
that we have to manage our terror by
keeping ourselves busy and having
trophies and competitions and awards and
you know stuff like that because it
gives us a sense of uh longevity and
life after death and like a lasting
legacy
you know because we have so much
existential panic that we have to manage
yeah yeah there's a lot of reality in
that
at the same time i think there's parts
of it that are true and there's parts of
it that are constructed so the
constructed parts almost keep us
imprisoned in that in that uh hamster
wheel
but then there's parts of it that have
because it all comes from a true essence
like i think everyone agrees
that we feel like we want to feel
fulfilled yes and we want to feel
meaning and we want to feel purpose but
then the
constructs that have been created to
keep you locked in
they're the ones that we all feel
uncomfortable with over the you know i i
talk about sometimes like in my school
that i went to and this was painful
so in my high school in london they
would give us
a rank system of 180 students and every
subject they would rank you
every year on where you were against
everyone else so
youtube it's it's youtube comments it's
ready it's youtube but
it's like for everyone to see so you go
home with this sheet of paper that you
give to your parents
that says you're either number one for a
subject or your number 180 for a subject
and you're showing it to them that's
like public shaming
i bet i i mean i mean
it probably worked it worked for me it
worked by showing me what i was really
good at what i was really bad at and i
was like all right those things that i'm
below 90 and i'm not gonna put any
effort into
and these these three five things i'm
doing really well i'm gonna go all in on
those by the way it is amazing to look
back at the shit
that was done when we were in school
that they don't do anymore because
everyone's like so delicate about
children yeah like you can they don't
give
trophies or prizes or first place so
they don't bring kids at all which i
actually think we've gone like too far
in the other direction
kids just suck at sports now like
they're just like all like a disaster
like i have this nephew who's like sucks
at soccer i'm like we need to bring back
the
we need to bring back these ribbons dude
these kids
he's just like rolling his ankle like
they're gonna get injured we need to get
some
motivation but yeah when i was a kid
like they would put your test results
like on the wall
yeah for everyone to see yeah but that's
the point right like as humans we do a
really poor job
of oscillating between extremes so we go
from one extreme to the other extreme
and the reason why the word balance has
been so popular for such a long time
is because the answer is somewhere in
the middle the answer is a bit of both
right there is a need for rankings and
competition and there is a need for
compassion and collaboration and it's
almost like embracing polarities
is so much more the direction that we're
all looking for
as opposed to saying that it's either or
and so when people say things like oh do
you need to be
spiritual or strategic to be successful
it's like well you need both yeah
do you need to be generous or do you
need to be focused on growing if you
want to be happy you need both like
you can't it's not really about a choice
in the same way as we started with self
and service
it's not one or the other you're making
me realize something i think that is
just
we all can look at we are we love black
and white thinking because humans love
can we want an
answer even if it's the wrong answer
yeah we just want to show true so that
we have some semblance of control and
i'm in this new relationship
and i find myself wanting to it's not a
relationship what am i saying black am i
thinking
it's somewhere in between we're not
dating and we're not together um
and uh and i'm i want
so badly to feel safe my inner child
needs an answer so bad
that i'm like do you like to travel or
do you not like to travel and he'll be
like well it depends on where i'm
traveling and i'm like well what's the
you know and so do you cheat or do you
not cheat he's like well i've
it's different with me yeah none of
these answers are going to apply to me
because this is a new situation but it's
made me realize
how anxious you know preoccupied and how
much i perseverate um
and how much my inner child panics when
she doesn't have an
answer yes and i think if we just
acknowledge like
you talk about in this book and um are
being so elegant about it now if we just
acknowledge
our need for the polarity
we can then release it it's just like
even the awareness of knowing
is he an asshole is he not well he's
probably sometimes an asshole and
probably sometimes not is she a bitch or
not well
sometimes i'm a bitch and sometimes i'm
sane totally and we're all so much more
and percentages in different scenarios
than we are one or the other
and it's the same thing i say to people
when they're like oh jay you know i
don't know if my intention is completely
pure or if it's material or spiritual
i'm like
we're both all of it like it's all of it
like me too like we all are like you're
just
you're always trying to move in the
right direction the problem is we're
addicted to a right decision
right and that's the problem we're just
trying to move into the right direction
we're just moving closer to that
and as long as you're moving closer in
the right direction with someone with
yourself with whatever it is that you're
learning
don't give so much emphasis to the
decision
that the direct answer yeah you know the
destination all of that kind of
you're so right about what you just said
about the child and so many of us not
having had clarity
as young people about where we stood
with our parents or where we stood with
our partners and now we demand what we
did or didn't get
yeah from our parents in our
relationships it's the unfinished
business
yeah you know it's sort of like it took
me so long to stop recreating my
childhood circumstances because i think
we have this
subconscious pull obviously to recreate
the neurochemical cocktail that's
comfortable
for us it's like when you see someone in
a crazy relationship you're like how do
they deal with that all day
they're in a cocoon they are so
comfortable doing it that is all they
know
it's like the devil you know and um and
i find myself recreating my childhood
circumstances and yes
trying to basically just heal that wound
heal that wound who's going to heal it
who's going to fix it and it's there
no one no you have to do it yeah there's
a beautiful statement that you reminded
me of by a monk named tik nathan
he's incredible and and he said that we
choose
familiar pain over unfamiliar pain
every time we just repeat it because
that familiar pain
gives us a feeling of safety of security
of like i know
what pain i'm going to feel and i'd
rather keep repeating it
then maybe venture out into this new
land of unfamiliar pain
which i don't know what it feels like
it's comfortable yeah yes it's like that
pair of heels that always gives you a
blister i got the band-aid like
it's amazing how and i think that i'm
glad that we're talking about this
because
we are so adaptable like there's so many
people that
reach out to me and they're like is it
too late for me to change is it too late
for me to go to allen on meetings is it
too late for me to stop being jealous
and possessive and a love addict or a
sex actor or whatever and i'm like dude
we think about how quickly you adjusted
to those sandals that are giving you
blisters you were like just put in a
band-aid and i'm just gonna take them
off after an hour at the wedding like we
actually can adjust absolutely so
quickly
you know that is a great analogy i'm
gonna i'm gonna share that now from now
on i love that one i'm gonna be like
yeah whitney and me were like yeah this
is
that is a brilliant analogy i love it
you're gonna talk about blisters
and heels and yeah everyone's like okay
i'm gonna check your number
like when i wear heels you'll really fit
in hollywood um
okay there's a vedic personality test in
your book will you tell me about it
yeah absolutely so i really believe that
passion
and purpose are again these themes that
are thrown around which can i just
not i'm really i get too excited
sometimes in podcasts and i interrupt
and i'm really working on do it
i love that you say that because
happiness i don't like the word happy
it confuses me i feel too much pressure
i don't i don't know how to describe it
i don't know when i'm feeling it purpose
and fulfillment
i know what that is happy i sort of tune
out it's like it's a childish immature
word to me personally
and i'm so glad you don't use it i love
that because there's so much bullshit
like
fake how to be happy on like bullshit
instagram stuff that's like
vague and amorphous and i don't i just
it's
anyway just i love fulfillment and
purpose
well i'm fortunate because all of my
kind of dictionary definitions come from
the vedas
and the bhagavad-gita so for me it's
like i'm simply trying to extract
and share all these incredible teachings
that i learned so when i lived as a monk
and we studied the vedas
i came across this incredible concept
named dharma
and dharma is very difficult to
translate into english but when you do
it the closest things are
eternal purpose and inherent nature
or your natural inclination and those
are things it's almost like well what is
your
natural most effortless flow-filled
state
that you can live by that you feel
fulfilled in right and so
when you break that down you get dharma
basically equates to an equation which
is passion
plus strengths plus compassion so it's
when your passion
what you enjoy what you thrive at what
comes naturally to you girl
matches with your strengths look at him
blow past that you're unbelievable
like nothing throws you this really is
i love it think like a monk like i
cannot throw anything at you
this is amazing i love it i love it i i
was actually gonna i was actually trying
to tee you up for
so you said passion not strength
strength adderall
okay and then compassion um okay there
we go
there we go so let's put the let's let's
look at the synergy between those three
and you can help me out here energy
through them yeah uh yeah there we go
there we go it is
it is it is it is of three yeah three
things
what is at the center of all of that
that is dharma
and so the personality test that i give
is to help people and i've loved
so first of all there is no personality
test or
astrological chart that's going to give
you the answer that you need
but they're good indicators and scenes
you're trying to say astrology is not a
science
jam tell me i mean it is a science for
me but i'm not sure
how many people can do it properly uh
but but the idea that
this personality test was put in there
to help people get closer to the answer
and that's what i think all of these
tools do it's just about moving you in
the right direction but you're making me
realize like
when i go out in the world and i'm you
know dating somebody or
you know talking to a potential new
employee or meeting a possible
new friend candidate i spend all this
time
trying to learn about them when i've
spent no time learning about myself
totally i'm like what kind of person are
they have they done this and do they
like this and do they
lie do they cheat i'm like what about
fucking me why don't i give myself this
test
and then i'll know how to gravitate
people of the right frequency because
then i'll know who i
am it's like what i say about like love
like you know
this is a hot take but um to me i'm like
i i don't decide if i'm in love with
someone based on their behavior it's
based on my behavior around them yeah
am i calm am i thinking of them are i
accept
is it bringing out the best in me or am
i like a jealous mess
you know who's checking their phone
that's not love that's possession
infatuation and
old shit you know i love that so it's
like i want to do a couple of these
yeah let's do it has anyone done this
has anyone given you the vedic
personality test
i've done it on my own but publicly oh
no no no no oh great oh let's do it oh
great oh great yeah i love that hi this
is
i just love this book because it's like
it's real tools i'm sorry there's a lot
of bullshit out there there's a lot of
like
buy a crystal water bottle and your life
will get better like what are you
talking about
use charcoal toothpaste and you'll find
your soul mate like this is
actual like how to rewire your brain how
to get to know yourself better with
actual tools instead of just like
bullshit random
quotes that are always attributed to
oscar wilde even though he didn't say
half that shit and we know it
um okay you're gonna answer these
questions uh as who
you believe you are at the core beyond
what friends family or society have made
you choose
which of the following sounds and i want
you guys to follow along and take this
quiz with us i like it
which of the following sounds most like
what you're about values and wisdom
integrity and perfection work hard play
hard or
stability and balance yeah so very
important question i'm going to add a
caveat to help everyone out as well
seeing as this is the first time
everyone's
doing it publicly with us everyone's
follow along get your pen and paper is
is you're not trying to answer it as
what your job's made to you you're not
trying to answer as what you've become
because of something like sometimes
we become something because we had to
become it to be more successful you want
to answer it at your core
and the closer you get and that's hard i
get that that's that's not easy to do
but the more you keep answer asking
yourself the question sometimes they say
to this like the first thing you think
of is you
that's actually not true it's it's
actually you need more stillness
silence and solitude and space to
actually slow down a bit
and go well what am i really and it's
also not your ideal self
so that's the other mistake see extremes
again we oscillate between
our society self and our ideal self so
then people answer it like oh yeah
that's the one i want to be so it's not
that either have you thought about
starting a cult
no you should you would get very rich
i just started i just got emotional um
because when you said not who people
told you to be or wanted you to be
as i'm looking at this whoo i was like
well this is what my dad would have
wanted my dad would have wanted
uh work hard play hard and i was gonna
pick work hard play hard
it should be work hard cry hard uh
that's a good one but i think i'm values
and wisdom
yeah and so i am too i'm a values bitch
i'm like
a this is wrong like i uh and sometimes
it veers into self-righteous indignation
and sometimes it's like
i miss the force for the trees because i
get so wrapped up and i have like a
value
that i can't compromise on um
but yeah i'm a values and wisdom yeah
what was the second one again
uh integrity and perfection yeah no i'm
the first one i i used to be integrity
and perfection
yeah yeah i used to be that when i was
young yeah it's
all about perfection like what the fuck
is it perfection anyway
yeah like running around trying to be
perfect in this like this this vague
definition of perfection is not even
real
yeah that's a that's a ruse yeah that's
just a hallucination
oh oh my gosh sorry i'm getting
emotional let's do i love it it's money
do you want i will give you start a cult
i'm serious
i just want to give you my money will
you be part of it will you like co-lead
it can i be can we co-create this
it can be the um can we did we just
co-create
right now i will totally
host it i'll host to the sex parties i
don't even know what happens in these
quilts but i'm
i'm happy to host them people can come
stay at my house um
what role do you pl this is a good one
what role do you play in your friend's
circle and family
hey i am comfortable dealing with
conflict and helping people find middle
ground my role is the mediator
sometimes this is the middle child but i
know and sometimes
if there's like boys in the girl
b i make sure everything and everyone is
taking care of my role as the protector
i feel like that might be me i have uh i
help my family understand work ethic
hustle and the value of having resources
my role is material support
i think i'm that now hit my venmo uh
d i focus on nurturing and wanting a
healthy and content family my role is
emotional
so i'll give it again another another
side note for everyone who's watching
and listening
you probably do all four of these i was
going to say i'm so glad we're doing
this together because
i've picked five different ones and now
that you're here yeah we can talk about
it that's the
point so so you're going to feel and
especially when you read these
you're always going to feel like you're
everything and the reason for that is
we've never really spent the time to
think about who we really are
and also i shape shift and i'm different
based on who i'm with and who people
want me to be correct
and so you want to pull back again and
go i am all for
but in which order am i right so you
want to break it down and be like well
which one do i prioritize the first so
i'll give an example
it's it's almost like if you were put
into a situation where you had to make a
choice which one do you say this is the
first thing i think about
right this is the first thing i think
about when it comes to my family
so if you heard if if someone called you
up and said i want to tell you something
about your family
which is the first thing that you think
of uh that comes to your mind
mediate would you protect your material
support or emotional correct like which
one do you feel drawn to play as a role
first and first correct first and most
because you are all of them we all are
i think protector right i'm i'm like
vicious about that
even if they're the even if they're
monsters i'll protect
monsters against another monster i'm the
mediator really yeah i'm the mediator i
have been since i was a kid like you're
switzerland you're neutral
is that it like yeah no i wouldn't say
i'm neutral
i would say that i'm yeah maybe i guess
that's the definition you're
non-judgmental
yeah you're the one that can see all
sides i try to yeah i've always been
that way and that really annoys my
family
because people in my my family would be
like why don't you see it from my side
more than you see it from there oh you
must be a nightmare
monk terrible terrible to have a monk in
the family there's no way you can ever
communicate me
yeah there's no way you can win a fight
with a mom like what a fucking nightmare
we're going to take a break from jason
from you and i
from james i would love to take a break
from you we were on a break
does better help have couples therapy
first of all how dare you say that
in front of our child sorry we have a
foster dog who benton is
trying so hard to make like him more
than me just to hurt me
yeah watch the footage on youtube so
what a wonderful company to talk about
coolest interviewing jay shetty because
we talk about self-awareness
edification improving your life your
relationships
self-awareness did i say that already
yeah is there something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving goals
yes you should get better help
better help will assist you your needs
and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist licensed
professional therapist not one of these
hacky mc
mc jacker bubbles
yeah not a not a street shaman who's
gonna
peddle you sage and and rocks they found
by a lady hucksters out there a lot of
charlatans out there trying to huck
their
fake psychology shit on you go to real
licensed therapy it's not a crisis line
it's not it's professional counseling
done securely
online i don't think people understand
how important that is you don't want all
your
secrets that you tell someone online in
a
private therapy session to get out this
isn't the nexium cult
yeah you don't want yeah this isn't
scientology you're not telling someone a
bunch of your secrets so they can get
leaked this is
secure therapy you do not have to be
worried about
divulging your deepest darkest secrets
it's available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime send a message
to your counselor you're going to get
timely thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly videos or phone sessions
which
truly is my dream because in person
therapy i think that is
that is literally like buying a record
player at this point
i'm just saying in person therapy by the
time you get there and you drive down
there and you wait no you're the meter
and you're looking for parking like it
stresses you out
therapy's supposed to relieve your
stress not cause you stress and then i
also i just get so distracted by noises
and sounds and smells and you go into
someone's
therapy office and it smells all musty
yeah and it is gross and better
what is the therapy offices there's a
little that little tree the little zen
tree with the sand
i'm not taking care of your tree while i
watch the office and i'm like why am i
paying for the
rent at this place why is this place why
does my therapist have a birkin
how messed up am i how long have i been
going here she hasn't fixed me yet
why does my therapist have an ostrich
birken bag
wi-fi therapist kris jenner bitch why
aren't you buying your shoes at
aldo why am i spending 300 an hour
so that you can shop at neiman's yeah i
need my therapist to not have paid off
their school debt yet yeah like i just
i really struggle with going to a
therapist office and all i think about
is how much is she paying or he
in rent or they are them or they are
them or z or
like why am i paying for this overhead
what's your overhead
you know i always think once you're over
because it's tricky because it's like i
don't want to go to
super expensive therapy in beverly hills
but then i also don't want to go out to
fucking in the middle of nowhere because
then i have to drive out to the strip
mall but that's the cost that makes
i don't know this is this i'm just
telling you listen better help want you
to start living a happier life today so
quit looking at motivational quotes on
pinterest stop taking your
therapy advice from marilyn monroe
betterhelp.com
whitney that's better h-e-l-p and join
over
one million people taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
sign of the times special offer for good
for you listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
whitney
you know that on this podcast
the biggest imprint i have left on
culture
is talking about bath towels yeah
the most dms i get are me saying i want
to see
dick pics because i want to see your
bathroom towels
am i allowed to say that in brooklyn and
no ad i'm pretty sure not well we're
going to try
because i'm making a good point and
they'll see that
so bath towels to me noth truly nothing
is more important
than what touches your body when you get
out of the bath
there's nothing worse than a towel that
doesn't absorb
oh or that like feel is sandpaper oh
though i already exfoliated thank you
very much don't need your help
sir yeah your towel should make you
bleed nope
and then the worst is when you know how
like oh when towels are just like
musty and they smell like molding and
gross
yeah there's nothing worse than a towel
that doesn't absorb and you're just
moving the water around you're like what
is what are we doing here
it's 20 20. how have we not figured
towels out of course
right why is my towel water resistant
why is this waterproof of course my
favorite sheet company makes the perfect
towels i'll figure it out
brooklyn of course of course the
freaking geniuses over there
were like why aren't we making towels
yeah i mean these are like spa towels
like they're like probably because they
were sick of me ruining their gorgeous
sheets with my wet ass body
like crappy towels yeah they're like can
you stop getting in bed soaking wet
you're ruining the brooklyn and sheets i
guess we have to make towels now and
also
like bath towels like are so key for me
because here's my here's my problem
i ruin my towels because i wash my face
with makeup on
but these ones they have so so i need
dark towels but i don't like
do black towels and you know that but
they have something called
what color is this do you see this gray
color what is that oh yeah it's like
that off-white kind of color no it's not
there's a gray
look at that oh the deep gray like steel
gray beautiful
that's the color i guess that's so
unlike you you're a whitetail beyond
we can't say bitch i'm a we can't in ads
you're a whitetail lady you got biotch
sorry brooklyn um they're cool they get
it they know me
sorry brooklyn it's like you're talking
to a girl um
so i love the plush bath sheet bundle
i do that as my towels towels but then
when i take my makeup off i use this
gray color
and it doesn't stain and it looks
gorgeous oh you have
two colors gorgeous that is smart i just
got the white one
their towels are like um it's like
wrapping yourself and like
it's like velvet but cake
it's like a hug it's like yeah it's like
oh it's like a it really is you know
when you get out of the shower like
whenever you're starting if you're
someone who takes
morning showers and you start your day
and you get out and you wrap that towel
around you and you're like i'm
ready for brooklyn and towels are like a
hug from someone
that you want to hug you not like one of
those hugs that lasts a little too long
not one of those this is like a hug from
like
your crush yeah it's like a mom hug
well okay or like we get it or your mom
loves you we get it okay
we get it you're like santa we don't i
don't do i have to tell you guys this
again we don't read the ads no
brooklyn is the perfect brooklyn we use
the product
we use the products so we don't have to
read we use the product and then we
guess that what they want to do we're
not robots
okay we like the product and then we
just riff
it's called talent brook linen is the
perfect place to find all the comfort
for home including ultra soft towels
they're so confident their products
and their products with everything a
lifetime warranty yeah they're so
confident in their products everything
comes to lifetime warranty
use promo code whitney for 10 off your
first order at brooklyn.com
that's do the rest of it i'm mouthing
what you're saying if you guys are
watching on youtube
that's b r o o k l i n
n promo code whitney
brooklyn in everything you need to live
your most comfortable life
what is most important to you and a
partner number uh
number a literacy a honest and smart
b strong presence and power c fun and
dynamic d
reliable and respectful e all of the
above no that's not
good credit yeah neither of them are on
there
again you want all four yeah it's better
again
and therefore a lot of relationships
come down into two areas
where we get to the polygamy part of uh
jay's
philosophy that's that's chapter 13. now
mormonism didn't make the book but
that's important because the two sides
of that
are in a relationship you have
priorities and preferences
right there are things that you will
prioritize that you really want in
someone
and then there have to be preferences
where you're like that's a bonus i like
that but it's not all going to be that
would be nice
yeah it would be nice exactly it would
be nice not essential i did that in my
book
uh we did the list for you guys that
don't remember we did
musts would be nice and red flags so
we're on the same yeah it's similar it's
a little bit similar but it's for love
addicts it's for
um uh people who are hanging by a thread
like me um
so what is most important to you and
your partner i wanted to say a
honest and smart yep and that is super
important to me but
strong presence and power i i'm
embarrassed to admit it and i'm ashamed
but i do lose attraction to people if
they don't
if they're not powerful like i like to
feel
you shouldn't be ashamed of that yeah
you shouldn't be embarrassed about that
at all
okay tall yeah all i care about's tall
i'm shocked sure
but you should no but i need i do need
someone who feels powerful who
i feel protected by looking for a father
but that's yeah but i get it
but you definitely shouldn't feel
embarrassed about it yeah and i think
that's partly what it is is that when we
do these activities
we kind of look for the one that makes
us feel the most comfortable and happy
rather than the one that's actually true
and that's why we attract the wrong
people into our life and that's why we
spend 10 years with someone and we're
not sure they're the right person but
because they
looked good on paper and just be honest
with you as i'm taking this quiz
i'm trying to impress jay with a good
answer instead of saying the truth this
is this is
and the truth impresses me more than
than the impressive answer
yeah people like you so much more well
like when you're trying to get
validation from people the irony is
trying to get it and being anxious
is what's repellent yeah so just being
honest is what makes people like you it
takes
taking me so long to realize that and
all of these ideas have been planted in
our minds like i didn't put this in the
book and i know that this is i remember
reading this in like marketing case
studies and books and it's been shared
of this this is so great so
i remember trying to not trying to i
remember deciding to propose to my wife
and this was 2014 that i proposed to my
wife who got married in 2016.
so i'm deciding to propose to my wife
and i asked my friends who proposed and
got married and i was like well okay
like where do i get a ring from and how
much do you spend
on the ring i don't know if you've heard
this before so literally all my friends
tell me
that you have to spend two months salary
on a ring right
and and i'm like i'm like okay and and i
i spend two months saturday on a ring i
propose my wife's really happy and all
the rest of it
then i start looking into it and i start
seeing all these videos
all these case studies showing how there
was a de beers commercial
and this de beers commercial if you can
watch it find it on youtube literally
google on youtube de beers commercial
diamond lasts forever
and literally this was a time where i
believe the diamond trade wasn't doing
that well
and so all these diamond companies went
all in on creating marketing campaigns
around diamonds being central to a
marriage
and a proposal and literally i kid you
not you can watch it on youtube
the last six seconds of this advert
says this is how you make a diamond
two months sorry this is how you make
two months salary last forever
how else can you make two months salary
lasts forever and that adverts from like
the 80s or the 90s or something and here
i am in 2014
living out that advert and i'm thinking
wow like is that how
my love my ideas around love have been
formed or uncreated
and and i would do them you know it's
just amazing when you face it that when
you go oh wow that wasn't even my idea
like that wasn't even real and so what
about it when you're answering these
questions
you want to move away from old
programming correct bullshit
unlearning that old program what is all
that and also like
it drives me nuts these just fake
standards that we don't even know
yeah like some mercenary huckster who
was going out of business said this
thing that got in the zeitgeist and it
became true
crystallized into a truth over time
totally question everything you think
about everything and including yourself
and love and
um you know uh i forgot what i was gonna
say i got too excited
um oh no it'll come back you know how um
in uh
the wedding gifts every year it's like
the first year is goal the second year
is paper or the third year
is wood you know like all these like
arbitrary things dude
fuck that like go look at the list i
think
year 10 is literally ivory it's like
dead elephants
like this is that's how old this is like
it's like dead
something that is illegal and inhumane
and just great like i looked at it and i
was like oh this is so sick like
all of this weird materialistic shit and
people don't talk about this enough and
i know this is a hot take that's going
to get me canceled but
people don't talk about the unrealistic
expectations put on men around this shit
you know like
people like romantic comedies women's
have romantic comedies and they have
these completely unrealistic
men saw them too oh we dragged them to
movies oh i tried to live a lot of them
like i took my wife out the first time
we went on our first ever date i took
her to this fancy restaurant
and thought that she was gonna love it
and she told me afterwards she would
have rather
walked down the isle at whole foods and
like you know she was just like this is
not me
but in my head i was completely
convinced that that's how you made
a woman feel special i remember watching
what was it bronx tale yeah there's
the movie bronx tale and in that movie
it said that if you get into a car with
a woman
and she doesn't lean over and open the
car door for you after you've opened the
car door for her then she's not the
right woman
wait a minute yes so so i'll give you an
example
no no no so i open the door for you and
you get in
got it right and then i walk around the
side to go to the driver's seat and if
you don't
lean over through the door and open it
for me then you are not the right person
and i remember seeing that in the bronx
style i've still never forgotten it and
and literally that would be like when i
was in my team
back this is my way leaning over and
opening your door
yeah i know i mean that would be wild
and then
and then you open it and a car drives by
and just hits the door i'm like that
doesn't seem to make any sense
it doesn't but it's in the wrong style
so it's so
many like fucked up messages we have
like i remember there was this time
where like um whenever a guy would fuck
up with me or lie or do something
um uh he would like show up at
my work or show up at the comedy store
whatever and make some grandiose gesture
and i was like
what do you do and i was like oh my god
there was like 10 years of romantic
comedies
where whenever a guy would cheat or lie
he would go to like an outdoor
basketball court with his
all white friends always and uh and
they'd be like dude you just gotta go
just go to her work go right now and
they would and the guy would run in
while
she would work of course at like a
magazine they all worked at magazines
and she'd be like giving a presentation
the guy would be
like knock on the glass and be like i
have to a pot like
it was always like go to her work
because it's a woman what how important
could her job be
yeah and guys learned like go to
someone's
a woman's job and apologize
like and guys would do it guys were like
showing up at airports to stop women
from getting on flights
like
how did you even get through tsa totally
i'm going to be late for this flight i
don't know
are you paying for the return exchange
fee like what's happening so i didn't
forget and i know a lot of people you
know and i understand why that's in the
zeitgeist right now of like unrealistic
expectations for women but it happens
with men too and you guys are
expected to be chivalrous but not too
chivalrous because that's patronizing
and i can open my own fucking door and i
can carry my own fucking purse and i can
pay for my own fucking meal and you know
it's like
you know i think there's a lot of
confusion that we're not talking about
yeah i think everyone obviously has
their own blocks and challenges and
misconceptions and that's why it's it's
such a personal process to have to
unlearn all of this
you literally just remind me of that
notebook scene where
ryan gosling literally says that he will
drop himself from a ferris wheel if
uh rachel mcadams does not agree to be
on a go out on a date with him
and it's like if someone died so hot
it's like if someone literally told you
that they were about to kill themselves
like it's a very serious topic like it's
a really serious
issue if someone really said that to you
in real life and so
it's so romantic i mean it was like that
movie twilight like i was like oh this
is bullshit i'm watching and i'm like oh
my god
like if he kisses her she'll he'll kill
her he'll like tear her apart and eat
her and i'm like that's so hot
like there is some fucked up primal shit
going on that is just like
the elephant in the living room yeah um
but there is so much to
unlearn and i'm realizing how much shame
is coming up around this stuff
um this is a good question that i
struggled with answering
uh what do you watch most often on tv a
documentaries biographies and human
observations
b entertainment politics current affairs
c comedy sport drama motivational
stories
d soap operas reality tv family gossip
daytime shows
i realize and i'm curious if the motive
matters because i definitely watch
documentaries biographies the most
but it's because i'm insecure about my
intelligence and i
always i i look at it's embarrassing to
admit but
i look i watch tv as a way to try to get
smarter to try to get information to
try to be interesting um and to try
because my biggest fear in life is being
boring in a conversation
or not knowing something that someone
else knows and
or like having the fomo in a group where
everyone's seen something i haven't so
it's like if everyone's watching a
documentary i'm like i have to watch it
so that i'm not
left out so does it matter that that's
why i want
pick a no because it's mixed again so
what i heard in there is there's a lot
of values and wisdom there like you want
to have more knowledge you want to have
more insight now the reason you want to
have it
isn't perfect but that's not bad it's
still a great it's better to be informed
than uninformed yeah so you're winning
already but i think
all of us have to move in our values so
i'll given it this is going to
sum it up really beautifully in the
bhagavad-gita there's three intentions
behind everything and they're either the
mode of ignorance
the mode of passion or the mode of
goodness so there are these three modes
that any action any habit any intention
can be done in so the mode of ignorance
is when you do things out of fear
or anxiety the mode of passion is when
you do things for desire or result
and the mode of goodness is when you do
things from love or compassion right
or curiosity like that kind of like love
or thirst
and so in that our most of us including
me our our
uh state of being is very mode of
ignorance we do most of what we do out
of fear and anxiety
and the problem with that is is that
when you do something out of fear and
anxiety it doesn't suddenly transform
into love and compassion or joy
or meaning or purpose it stays that way
and continues to perpetuate that cycle
of
needing to get more of that fear and
anxiety so that's something that we can
push an
upgrade from so next time you want to do
something and you're watching a
documentary be like
all right right now i'm starting this by
doing it because i'm scared of not
looking smart or not being
conversationalist
but actually you know what this time i'm
going to intentionally change my
intention
to be because i'm going to do this i
just love being informed and i want to
be informed so i can share this and you
literally do that intentionally and you
will see
how your experience changes it's it's
that metaphysical like literally sitting
there and just
literally walking yourself through it
and changing
your mindset around something can change
your experience of it
and also having you're making me realize
how much i bully myself because it's
also you can have compassion for that
too it's
there's nothing wrong with wanting to be
smart nothing at all nothing wrong with
going i'm going to watch this
documentary because everybody else is
watching it i'm finding that i tend to
over pathologize myself sometimes
because i've
i'm like so committed to not being crazy
and not committing
you know uh uh sort of recreating the
ancestral trauma and the stuff that i
saw i'm so
committed to breaking the cycle
sometimes and i think anyone that is
going to be following you or
listening to this or listening to this
podcast like you know don't
over self-help to the point of
self-flagellating
even when you're not doing anything
wrong yeah do you know what i mean like
we don't have to over examine to the
point
of you know perfectionism and and over
criticizing nothing no and actually
that's the worst that as soon as you
feel guilty
or judge yourself or criticize yourself
you actually start
losing energy to that and that's the
same energy that's going to help you get
out of that and so
as as monks it was almost like you would
laugh when you'd catch yourself
letting the monkey mind go loose and so
in the beginning in the book as we got
the monkey mind and the monk mind
the monk mind almost laughs when it
notices the monkey and goes ah okay i
saw you i see you i see you my fear
i see ego i see what you're trying to do
there and it's that kind of like fun
playful
spotting it's almost like you just saw
your dog running around outside you're
like
i can't exactly
i love that and that's something we do
in half-step programs is you befriend
your character defects because they are
trying to protect you they're trying to
help you it's like
when your dog goes out and barks at the
mailman and you're like you know it's
not a threat but the dog is just trying
to protect you you know and so
and the off chance that the dog's right
when it isn't the mailman like yes
because sometimes those those tools
worked really well and there were real
threats back in the day and those tools
weapons were very necessary but they
just they're now obsolete like
the war is over right as we say in
program the war is over you lost
like just and um and so i love that like
just sort of
having levity around the your negative
inner monologue or your negative
thoughts like you don't have to take
them seriously they don't have to it's
like watching star wars
it's it's just a it's just a science
fiction movie i'm not good enough he
doesn't like me i suck i'm gonna be
alone forever like you they
those don't have to be true it's like a
it's like a crazy person like
if you walked by a bum yelling crazy
shit like that you would just be like
okay that's a crazy
you just go oh those are just crazy
thoughts and they're silly and yeah
i love that and yeah and what we do in
um you know program is if you have a
character defect sometimes you name them
like your selfishness has
your name and you're like hey bill like
what are you doing here today oh you
want to come say hi like i don't need
you today i'm good
you know you can sit back on the bench
like don't need you in the game today
yeah i love that i love that yeah and
12-step program is amazing
it's so well designed from a human
psychology point of view and it's just
that naming peep voices in your head is
brilliant yes it's so important making
them characters because then otherwise
you think they're you
that's the point that's the whole point
of it yeah i love you
what causes you the most pain a feeling
like i don't live up to my own
expectations
be the state of the world see a sense of
rejection d
feeling disconnected from friends and
family yeah
that's a big one repeat the first one
again what uh feeling like i don't live
up to my own
expectations yeah is that the first one
yes yeah yeah
that can be that's yours you think yeah
that's definitely mine what causes you
the most
pain this is a tricky one um
being rejected by men i don't even like
um
yeah that one feeling like i don't live
up to my own expectations
yeah that's definitely my line but but
my own expectations are
outrageous they're ridiculous
but that's why we shouldn't feel that
yeah and by the way
i've achieved most of them against all
odds
i should just be like thinking i'm
awesome you should
and instead i'm like i achieved that
impossible thing but i was wearing the
wrong shirt
yeah and i had sweat stains you gave a
terrible speech yes
yeah gave a terrible speech you get or
i'll go like like you killed with that
speech and then i'll be like oh god how
much attention do you need how are you
desperate like oh yeah
we do that we're constantly it's just
like it's just so roasting myself
roasting yourself yeah and it's it's
just it's
that's why again i think going back to
that levity point of
finding the joy finding the fun in
something not taking it too seriously
but
but with this one with the pain point
it's it's really interesting to know
what causes you the most pain because
then you can actually get close to it
and address it and so this question
isn't again and
and i noticed that i love how we're
doing this because so many of you at
home may be listening or watching and
saying
actually you know i feel just like
whitney where when i'm reading this
i just feel embarrassed about who i am
and actually like
that's there's no point in feeling that
or if you do feel that allowing yourself
to feel that but then still looking and
getting closer to it is actually what's
needed
and i think that is by design you know i
think we were
um as children told relax calm down that
feeling's not
valid feelings aren't true that's why
they're feelings
right feelings aren't facts so it's like
you know i think if
if you had if we had had this
conversation five years ago
i would be like no i don't feel that i
don't i was in such denial about my
feelings you know because i was taught
that feelings were weak
and especially as a woman you're
emotional you're crazy you're neurotic
you're sensitive and so i feel like i
was in so much denial about them anyway
so
you know i love that we're doing this if
i can do this publicly you guys can do
it private yeah this is genius this is
so genius i love this because
and with the expectation one that's been
really interesting for me because i
agree with you so
i have been able to live a life that
surpassed
all my expectations like i didn't expect
anything like i never thought anyone
would care about any of the stuff that
i'm sharing at all when i started
i just really believed in the message
and believed in the wisdom and that's
why i started
and and at the same time i i feel a
great sense of
joy feeling humbled by my
expectations of myself right in the joy
of
wanting to channel be more connected
be more deeper in my practices almost
from a point of view of like
not taking on the pressure for myself
that's what helps me is realizing that
hey this
isn't about you this isn't just about me
there's there's wisdom books there's
traditions there's there's messages i'm
trying to share out there
and also know what your monkey mind is
doing like
you know when you're disappointing
yourself or you're not in my case
in you know because i picked i feel like
i don't live up to my own expectations
like
i know what i'm doing i'm creating
impossible expectations so i feel like
i'm not good enough because that's how
i felt in my family of origin and i'm
just recreating a comfort zone
like what if i'm good enough then what
yeah then what
it's not getting those neuro chemicals
i'm not getting that familiar pain
that you were talking about and then
what you know so it's you know something
my
sponsor said the other day she goes um
your motto for the week
is let it be great yeah just let it be
great like let yourself be what happens
if you're
great yeah what happens if nothing's
wrong what are you gonna do with
yourself
you know because for me if everything's
fine or i've achieved something or
like you know celebrating it's um the
damocles sword is hung and the other
shoe is going to drop i associate good
feelings with
when is this going to go away so i'd
rather just stay in the bad feelings
because then i don't have to deal with
the loss yeah you've just reminded me of
one of my favorite stories that that
actually i didn't put in the book it's
uh
it's a story told by the buddha the
feeling you'll get another offer for a
book
have a feeling you'll have a sequel here
it's a it's a story that the buddha used
to tell
and in this story it's like uh this this
person comes across
a river and it's a fast-flowing river
and the person wants to get across to
get to their destination
and so they're looking at and going okay
well what do i do what do i do what do i
do
and they start noticing that there's
some bamboo sticks around there's they
can find some rope they can find some
things to make a little
raft so they start gathering all of this
stuff laying it on top of each other
trying to tie it all up together and
they finally create this raft
and then they create a little ore with a
stick and then they go onto the water
and they get to the other side
and when they get to the other side they
go this person says oh wow this this
raft
literally saved my life like this raft
is amazing
without this raft i would never have
crossed this river and so what they do
is they strap the raft to the
to their back because they're like i
have to take this raft with me because
it's so important to me
and so they start walking start walking
start walking and now as they walk away
they now come
through one of the most wooded lands in
the world so all these trees are in
front of them
and they start trying to get through and
they realize that they can't get through
because this raft is strapped to their
back and they're trying to like maneuver
and swish through
and then they come to a realization the
person realizes that actually this raft
that got them here
is not going to help them go through
this and they have to let go of the raft
they have to let go of the thing that
actually saved them in the past to help
them get through the past
because it's no longer relevant today
and and the buddha obviously goes on to
tell us that
that's our habits that's our mindsets
that's even our skills and our strengths
we may have had something that saved us
five years ago
10 years ago but don't hold on to it
because you think it's still useful
because actually it could make your life
life a living hell like trying to get a
raft through the wooded land
would actually be a lot harder but what
if there's another river then you'll
build another one then you build another
roth that's the point you're building
that bridge you'll figure out again
because you know you've done it before
so that you can always go back to but
sometimes you have to leave behind the
tools
or at least put them back in the toolkit
for now and learn another tool or learn
another approach
and i think that's what 12 step is
that's what this is that's
everything we're discussing is just us
going oh well there may be a tool that i
haven't yet go in my toolbox that's
going to help me
which is why we say one day at a time
because you go not yesterday not
tomorrow what about just now
yeah right you know so stop trying to
solve problems or anticipate problems
from five days from now
and you can't stay clean on the shower
you took yesterday like stop
that you know so it's like um i love
that
and if you don't start a cult you hate
money because i am
so in what is your favorite way i'm dead
serious
we co-created one today though it was
co-created whole created
yeah but we need a cool name we need a
good name though like it needs a name
and needs a logo
yeah it needs a drink um
think like a monk also your next one
should be thank like a month about
gratitude
think like a monk because there's so
much in here about gratitude i'm i'm
fully work for you now
um what is your favorite way of working
for jay shetty
uh a alone but with mentors and guides
be in a team as a leader
see independently but with a strong
network d
in a team as a member ah
see i have this constitutional need to
be special and i'm like none of these
apply to me
because i'm so special which is mean i'm
glad you said that
it's important it's a big part of the
addictive personality to go no one
understands me no one knows the kind of
pain i'm in
i'm so unique no one will ever get me
which is why i need to do this addictive
behavior
and i'm different so i had i'm having a
little bit of that that's good
i'm having a little bit of it come up
right now um
i would say well because i'm like i do
this weird job where i do stand up and
it's
so i would say it would be independently
but with a strong network because i do
what i do independently but i couldn't
do it
without the fans in the audience yeah so
yeah it's this this question is all
about the energy that you thrive in
so a lot of people for example feel the
pressure today
to be leaders or entrepreneurs or ceos
because almost like there's this influx
of like excitement in the industry today
of seeing more people be founders and
now everyone thinks they have to be a
founder
or everyone thinks they have to be a
youtuber because that's the cool thing
and so
so it's like everyone wants to be the
front of house
interesting when actually a lot of us
thrive being steven spielberg right or a
lot of us thrive being the person behind
the camera a lot of us thrive being
the person the two wonderful people that
we have here today are recorded
like there's that's what we call that's
what my my therapist always says she's
like be a worker bee you don't always
just you have my matchbox with bees yeah
you don't always have to be
the face or the hero of every right
sometimes you're not the best qualified
everyone is sort of the queen bee of
their of
there's everyone's a um what did you say
everyone's the singer
yeah just the band looks different yeah
that's interesting
like like my producer is a singer like
everyone's a singer there's no
background
it's just a different dynamic yeah and
and
the uh that's definitely i i definitely
see total value in that mindset and then
you see it the
way that people can apply it to their
life so there's this great conversation
between steve wozniak and steve jobs
and they acted out in that the movie
that they made and so steve wozniak
and and i'm a big steve jobs fan and
it's if you haven't read walter
isaacson's book on him it's amazing
and so steve wozniak is looking at steve
jobs and having an argument and
he says to steve jobs he goes well what
do you even do and imagine looking at
steve jobs and going what do you even do
and steve wozniak goes you're not an
engineer you're not a coder you're not
an artist you're not a marketer or
whatever he says
he says what do you even do and steve
jobs says
he says musicians played their
instruments i played the orchestra
yeah and it's that understanding of the
unique
strength of like there may be the best
violin player
or there may be the best string quartet
there but his role was not being good at
any of those he doesn't have to play the
violin or the viola or the
whatever it is he knows how to bring it
together yeah and i think that's what we
get confused by sometimes is that
we see the people on the front cover of
magazines or the front of the show and
we think
that's who i need to be to be happy or
successful
it takes 50 people to make them the
person and you know
and it took me you know i made a movie
um and
i kept thinking i'm directing a movie
i'm directing a movie i'm starring in
the movie and you think i'm the most
important person here
i have all this pressure on me the most
important person on a movie set
is the sound engineer someone who they
will never know
his or her name necessarily they are the
most important person on a movie you
don't realize it till you get imposed
you know costume most important so so
you know i i
think that we are i'm so glad you
brought that up because we are
in such like a me moment i must everyone
can
be there's this um it's becoming more
democratic
the fame and wealth and rising to fame
and yeah it's like if
it it everything's a team and you have
to be able to play well with others and
respect other people's kind yeah
and actually as talent you'll respect
your team more because you'll realize
the value they bring
when you know your vedic personality
type in your dharma by the way we're
seeing
sorry uh more and more the people who
don't understand that are getting
cancelled yeah it's like it's the jig is
up yeah you know what i mean like the
people who are now
you there's that human resources
department
really get you yeah i'm the top one
again you're alone but with mentors and
guides correct i
i function best when i have a lot of
space when i have a lot of stillness
when i'm alone when i'm working with
myself
and i can tap into like people who've
really excelled in their fields
and by the way for a long period of time
that was just books like i grew up
reading
biographies and autobiographies because
that's all i had access to growing up
so i loved reading about mlk and malcolm
x and steve jobs
and i david beckham who was the first
autobiography i read and it was just
yeah and it's just you know i was i was
drawn towards real life stories
because i couldn't ask them myself and i
think that we're just in such a like
butt butt butt culture but isn't that
person problematic culture like steve
jobs like
he of course yes of course he was a
dickhead sometimes
of course but you know the things that i
love about steve jobs number one i love
that he had a uniform
i'm not even joking the amount of
decision fatigue
like i wear the same thing all the time
because you know
when you wake up and by the time you
pick your shoes and your outfit and your
makeup and your hair it's like you've
already exhausted your brain
and you've already made 50 decisions at
8 a.m so that was such a big part of why
he did that and i think we can all learn
from that because if i learn anything
from
having to interview hundreds of people
over the years it that no one gives a
shit
what you're wearing yeah and you've
wasted so much time and energy on it so
i love that about him and then there was
also the story i don't know if it was in
the book
about sort of like you know we just
talked about perfectionism but i think
this is the type of what i call like
healthy good perfectionism because it is
ultimately self-care and just good
business of
he they had made the ipods remember the
ipods and
he they were tiny they were these little
tiny ipods and he was like can it be
smaller and they were like it's the
smallest
music machine that's ever been made he's
like but can it be smaller and he they
were like well
like why don't we just put these out and
then we'll try to make him smaller later
and he walked over to the fish tank and
he put the ipod on the fish tank
and a little bubble came up and he goes
there's air in here it can be smaller
and they pull and this is what i loved
about it they had already made like a
couple million of them and they were
like well why don't we just
release these and then the next round
will make them smaller and he said
that's what other companies would do
yeah so they waited a year to release by
making it
imperceptibly one bubble smaller and it
just
it made me think like just wait just
measure twice cut once
just wait do it right the first time uh
and don't settle for that like yeah
we'll just fix it next time around yeah
i'm sure you had with
your book or when you kind of just when
you want to give up and go it'll be so
much easier
to just do this just go that extra mile
yeah absolutely absolutely and it
depends on
i always feel like with the yeah i had
adam i haven't shared this for a long
time but
there was a mindset i had about to make
it simple for myself with the small
things
be impatient and with the big things be
patient so it's like if you're putting
out like a
like if i'm putting out a post on
instagram or a video or like something
that's
almost like uh ephemeral in the sense
that it's you know it
it's gonna be relevant for like 24 hours
and then the noise takes over
with that i'm not going to obsess over
getting it right because you can't and
you're going to learn more by putting it
out there
so if i have a thought or an idea and
i'm like i want to see what people think
let's tweet it out let's hear what
people say
i love the one that you put up the other
day obviously i was reading out to my
wife
i'm doing a lot of putting them out and
taking them down these days it was
oh no i haven't got reception in here i
haven't got data but um
it was a really good one but if you have
a thought like that you put it out and
then you get feedback
but if i'm putting out a book that i
truly believe has timeless
thoughts and wisdom in it then that's
gonna require more cultivation and more
focus and you know what is making me
realize we talk a lot on this podcast of
how to get self-esteem right so
a lot of people these instagram posts
are like have self-esteem have self-love
and it's like fucking how
that's not science you can't get it by
liking an instagram post that's not how
it works
and we talk about self-esteem and pride
and i think we forget about
pride um being a sort of close relative
to self-esteem and
you know the way it was explained to me
that resonated was in order to have
self-esteem you have to do esteemable
actions
whether it's service your behavior pride
so when you do something at work and put
in that extra hour or put in that extra
day or that extra week or whatever it is
you're investing in your future self
because you get to have pride in the way
you behaved
so at the time you're kind of like ah
this isn't worth it and i fucking hate
my boss or i've already worked too hard
on this or whatever your inner child
petulant you know reactions are you
get to benefit later and you get to live
being proud there's no worse fucking
feeling
than me looking back at my book or a
movie i made or a tv show i did where
i'm like
fuck no one else cares but i have to
sleep at night knowing i fucking
gave up at the finish line yeah like i
gave 80 percent and like
i have to live with that forever and
then my self-esteem takes a hit yeah and
and that's and that's a positive way of
looking at it because it's like you know
if you
didn't do your best and even if everyone
else loved it if you're true to yourself
you'll know that it could have been
better yeah and that lets you die
and that's self-esteem self-esteem for
me it was also like very simple like
you know especially in this pandemic
everyone's home like putting on a pair
of fucking pants and putting on a bra
and carrying myself with dignity and
integrity and you know that
is how we build self-esteem yeah and the
opposite's true too that you may create
something that you think is beautiful
and no one will appreciate but because
you know what you put into it you'll
still value your invisible yeah
that's so powerful yeah that oh
okay i love that because a lot of people
are like the fucking people came at me
in the comments and i'm like but did you
agree with them
yeah if you didn't agree with them it's
not going to hurt you know
if you really were proud of that thing
if you really gave it your all
no one can fuck with you yeah some of my
favorite videos are my least watched
videos
or at least like my some of my favorite
podcasts i've recorded at least watching
has been four million views
only 20 million people watch this one
[Laughter]
but even with podcasts like my least
listen to podcasts like sometimes
what i feel like oh i was just you know
yeah on on fire like
you know having a moment of like this
revelation and no one sees it but
i still feel satisfied that i put it out
yeah yeah and you know there were a
couple this year i did these uh podcasts
which were like it was called interviews
with the daily departed so what i would
do is i would
research the work of people i look up to
that passed away
and then i would interview them with
questions that i would ask them today if
they were alive
so it was it was fascinating to try and
find answers in the work of martin
luther king malcolm x
steve jobs and other many other people
about things that
i thought that they said that were
powerful in the past that still apply to
today yeah
and it was like no one resonated like it
didn't do well
but but i loved the approach like i
loved the process of like researching
and like
and it was like no one wanted to hear
people unfortunately in my videos for me
like my angelou i did my angelou and
then you know i would have done one for
you know uh it would have been amazing
to do one with rbg like you know like
like that's the kind of thought process
that i had behind it but did she
can you imagine if i found out from you
right now i know i'm
i was just like what what if you
delivered the news to me this is gonna
change
yeah it's like you you really have not
been on instagram i was like oh what
place a prank on a month
god i'm sorry you got me i'm sorry you
got me though
because because it was leading into my
honesty i was like oh no oh no that's
your eyes i was feeling for you because
i had an experience the other day with
someone else that i was about to
interview and we didn't get to do the
interview because they just found out
like that second moment it really
affected them um
how would your ideal self spend spare
time a reading and deep discussion and
reflecting
be learning about issues and or
attending political events
see there's no such thing as spare time
networking connecting
working that's mine d enjoying time with
family and friends mine would be there's
no such thing as spare time networking
connecting working
that's weird i've i've definitely i've
i've done eight years of allen on and
codependents anonymous that would have
been me
uh shit
do i have a personality disorder no
i don't know you should die i can't i
can't verify that this is a hard one
there's no such thing as spare time
networking connecting working but here's
what i'll say
this is how much of a workaholic i am i
and how i think i've learned
to manage my time i'm very lucky that a
lot of the people i work with are my
friends
yeah yeah so a lot of my networking
connecting working
is my time with friends kind of but it's
for the gram
yeah okay but it's for likes yeah i get
it
again you have to be telegenic you've
got the high pass
you have to have at least a million
followers right okay it should be my
friend
to qualify this is very healthy yeah i
saw that banner on the outside
ushered in very quickly yeah oh what
does this say about me so i think it's
there's no such thing as spare time yeah
that's mine i have shame around it but
it's the truth but there's no shame in
this yes
yeah there's no shame in it it's fine
okay it's who you are you're right
you're right the idea is to get to know
your authentic self not judge your
authentication
and then decide whether you want to then
i can actually address it correct yeah
then otherwise what we do is we make our
intentional and ideal self feel like who
we are right so
what we do is we go okay that's the one
i feel embarrassed about being
yeah so i'm actually just gonna say i'm
my ideal self in my heart because that's
what i'm really trying to be
so i'll give an example of what i mean
by that there's a there's a really good
uh
study that i share in the book about the
good samaritans so the good samaritans
obviously trained to be good people and
do good in the world and be kind to
people
they're told that they have to give a
speech on being a good samaritan
and they have to go from their classroom
in building
a to the exam room in building b where
they'll be tested and have to give this
speech
but they're told literally like 15
minutes before they have to do it so
they're all stressing out
so they're stressing out this dressing
out stressing out they run down the
building uh they're trying to run across
to their exam room because they're told
you've got 15 minutes you've got to give
this speech
they're practicing on the way and
someone with a really hurt leg
is lying on the floor the decoy it's not
real and there's someone with a hurt leg
lying on the floor and they found that
over 50 percent of the good samaritans
ignored the person who was in pain
on the floor to go and give a speech
about being a good samaritan
so they didn't actually do the act of
being a good samaritan
and that's what happens when our
intention of being a higher self doesn't
match with the action of being a higher
self
and so when you're addressing you say
actually you know what i should have
stopped and taken care of that person
and helped them up and
you know been better to them and okay
well then i can change to become that
but if you just ignore it and go
oh yeah but i know what the value is i
know what the higher value is does that
make sense yes total sense
no i was just my comedian brain kicked
in go on and i was just like
how good of an actor was the person
pretending
that is a really good point i think i
think you should make sure that you go
into these
studies and make sure they pick good
actors if the casting was terrible
and everyone was like i have to go ahead
i'll come back later and do this
weirdness
that is brilliant that is brilliant i
love that
that is brilliant i've never thought of
that all along it was the badass
when you're really in pain you're just
kind of quiet and you start to sit there
like my legs and the ketchup yeah
how would you describe yourself in three
words a idealistic
introverted insightful be driven
dedicated determined c passionate
motivated friendly
d caring loving loyal yeah as your as
your
guiding force of how you live your life
on a day-to-day basis like that's how
you have to look at this question it's
like
when you wake up in the morning what's
the first thought that comes to your
mind you know is it is it driven is it
deterministic i'm going to take a crush
like my photo yeah that's my first
thought every morning i think i've been
liking a lot of them you have been
yeah yeah they've been really good so
you got my check yeah um
i don't know i didn't get it i had the
money yeah
[Laughter]
i don't think so i have to be honest i
want to be passionate
motivated and friendly and i think i am
those things but if i'm going to be
honest
i'm be driven dedicated and determined i
wake up like
me too gotta gotta achieve something
gotta do it i'm with you on that gotta
be passionate motivated and friendly and
caring and loving and loyal it's like
you know so i think it's c uh in what
type of environment do you work best a
remote still
silent natural be a meeting room or
gathering place see anywhere and
everywhere
uh d a specific um a space specific to
my type of work home office laboratory
i think i work best in a meeting or
gathering space i do need to be
accountable i need and i need to be
um a little bit competitive if i'm gonna
be honest i need to see other people
working
even if it's a if they're not even
working even if they're secretly on
facebook and watching porn or whatever i
pretend they're working and i think i'm
falling behind and it motivates me
see the reason why what you just did and
this is what i'm hoping everyone's going
to do when they read this part
is it's so important to know that
because now you actually have a pattern
that you can repeat
until it's not true and so most of us
wake up in the morning and we go
i'm not motivated to work today i don't
like
what i'm going to do today i'm not happy
to do whatever it is and it's like
well have you created the right
environments have you put yourself in
the right space set yourself up
have you exactly that's all it is and
the only way you'll know that is if you
answer that question and have the
reflection you did and go
okay well if i go to a gathering place
today or if i go to this place and i'm
around other people let me see how i do
and then you'll go and you'll test it
out and then you'll be like okay that
didn't work let me try the other one
right and so if you're unsure
it's just about trying all of these
options rather than just leaving it up
so right and also just in just
surrendering to something not working
going i guess this is the way it's
always going to be
exactly like that's me with exercise
like i am
i am not good with holding myself
accountable i will go exercise i'll be
on my phone half the time
i'll be standing around i'll decide i
need to like clean
the bathroom tiles and then i'll be like
oh well i guess i just didn't work out i
get distracted
if i work out with a buddy i i don't
need to change this about myself i don't
need to go to therapy and totally
i just need a buddy i just need to have
a buddy with me and that's it
absolutely yeah that's that's that's
literally that's me i need i need to
have
my trainer with me that's the only way
i'm gonna get it held accountable i need
to try to impress somebody i need to see
them working out so i feel like a slob
comparatively i need
i need my friend my comedian friends
filming me so that i'm trying to impress
instagram like
it i don't need to change that about
myself i don't need to go i need to
figure out a way to work out a lot i
love it i don't have time for that it
doesn't
i accept that about myself but the
definition of insanity we talk about
doing the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result just make
another choice
yeah just work out with a friend exactly
give it a go it's so easy yeah that's it
easy that's that one what's your work
style so in reflective focused and
organized fast and rushed specific and
deliberate
same focus there with that question it's
just going deeper and deeper and deeper
and that's what i tried to do with the
33 odd questions is
is how deep can we go yes so that you
get really and
and that's what it is it's what we're
doing with it is actually what i'd love
this is genius like this is why you're a
genius
because because doing this with you has
brought about
far more interesting conversation than
anything else
but also because this is what how
everyone should use the book yeah
and that's why i love it so much with
your friends also do it with a friend
talk through it like it's just such a
and have people call you out like you
know i l
i would love to do this again with
friends going like that is totally not
you yeah
and then you get to see how you're
perceived by others and you know it's
like this is such a great way to like
excavate um your identity and
also have so much i'm reading this and
i'm like i'm kind of a badass
like i kind of you know what i mean you
can see i think we're just so
you know i feel like people at this
point in this is a like we were talking
about earlier
polarity thing like i feel like everyone
is either
thinks they're better than they are now
or thinks they're worse than they are
yeah
yeah the worst people i know have the
biggest egos and the best people i know
hate themselves yeah this is a nice way
to kind of get
some um you know congruence between what
you actually are you know like i'm going
like oh okay i've done more
i've i'm i'm further along than i
thought yeah yeah like i'm more
self-aware than i thought i was like i
don't have to
um uh keep believing that old story that
i wrote 10 years ago about myself or
that my parents wrote
for me or that my ex wrote for me or my
brother wrote for me like this is like
you're like rewriting your story yeah
how do you prepare for a vacation oh no
hey
by picking my reading material be having
a focused
plan of key sites to visit c with a list
of the best bars clubs and restaurants d
with an easy going attitude b for me b
uh
i'm sorry are you very good i mean we're
both virgos
september 4th and 6th yeah um having a
focused plan of key
sites to visit yeah that's so i don't
always have to do it though i am a
person that i'll pre-plan pre-plan
pre-plan which i i really encourage
everyone to do this because i'm i'm
realizing that i need something to look
forward to especially with everything
that's going
no we can't go to shows we can't do go
to movies we can't like
planning things to me is almost as good
as doing them yeah
yeah yeah just having it in the calendar
so i'm that person that and i drive my
wife crazy
i'm like i need a schedule for the day
to know what we want to achieve to do
the fact that your wife
has the one man that makes a schedule
and doesn't appreciate it
her and i will have words i'm like i
want to schedule and even if we don't
get to all of it i'm okay with that
but i want to know that we made a plan
and that we were trying to get to all of
you yes we're designed we need it i want
to know what what i'm going to
experience today but see here's where
we start thinking people don't care
about us in the sense of
because our answer is b we think that if
someone cares about me
then they will make a plan but what we
don't realize
is that that's not how they're wired so
for them how they feel loved and show
love
is easygoing number d letter d
and that's where it gets so fragmented
in relationships because we st so i i
would be like that with my wife i'd be
like
well you you obviously don't love me
enough because you're not organized
about the schedule of the day and she
was like but i just don't think like
that like my parents
never my parents always did all the
planning and we just went along with
what they did and whereas my parents
wanted me to plan and get involved
and so it's so interesting how we start
looking at these things as
gaps in our relationship and that's not
necessarily true
i'm literally gonna start crying again
because i
fill in the blanks silence lack of
planning
i turn into rejection and being
forgotten
about if you're not making plans or
giving a schedule
you've forgotten about me you don't care
and i'm not a priority
so i just had this happen where i'm
seeing someone who by the way has a busy
life
has all the things you wanted a partner
has stuff going on
and has a purpose and meaning you know
and
isn't addicty and infatuating obsessy
and i was like this person's not making
plans
this person isn't checking in with me
every day we don't have a schedule but
then shows up
when i do see him with like a gift and
here's a mask
and has been thinking about me yeah but
i need proof
yeah i my love language or my i need
constant check-ins which is like um
uh childish no it's not
because they also have a job like i
don't you know it's it's setting the
realism
it's being and the other problem is we
feel guilty
to share that with someone because then
we feel weak about it and they're needy
yeah they need it yeah you don't want to
be needy i don't want you to be needy to
me so i don't have to be needy to you
yeah i'm asking the other person to be
needy because i'm needy but
me and my wife went through this in a
massive way because i realized that when
i was growing up the way my mom
always apart from giving me a lot of
love personally the way
she showed up for me on my birthday was
she would always give me the one thing i
always wanted for my birthday it was a
very big deal for whatever reason
getting me the gift
that i wanted that year and so gifts
became my biggest love language
and my wife comes from a family where
they just spend quality time together
and they like her dad would take the day
off on her birthday and they'd do
something as a family and that kind of
thing
and so for me i'm like where's my gift
and
and and you know for her it's like
where's quality time and so we went
through this for a while where
i had to really express why gifts were
important to me because because of her
bringing she couldn't understand why
gifts were important
and because of mine i couldn't
understand and that's the point that
love is understanding and like
understanding takes time and
understanding means i'm okay with that
person having a different wiring this
should be a workbook for
couples too you should do this with your
person yeah because it'll help you
understand what the other person values
yeah correct
and you can't pretend you don't value
something like if you're gonna go like
no i don't care you don't need to call
me like
first of all you're lying yeah and uh
second of all
they'll never understand how to love you
and the things that you value not to say
you don't still need to work on that i
shouldn't need gifts yes i'll work on
that i've worked on it you can still
work with me no i'm the same way and i
make giving gifts
is how i show up no you give me a gift i
give you a gift if that's a good gift
and i was going to bring you a gift
today too so now i know
i know that you're a good person no i'm
a giving gifts person i don't like
receiving gifts it makes me feel awkward
and and you can't cancel the rolex
because yeah
it's outside like it's a big number one
book um
uh no i'm a giving gifts person but i
sort of
recreate and victimize myself with it
because i
give gifts and if someone doesn't
receive it the way i need them to
i then feel like they're not receiving
my life yeah oh yeah
if i if i give someone like
like a necklace and they're not wearing
it the next time i see them
i'm like it's not a real wear this right
now can i wear it
i don't think i don't think so you'll
break your neck i got him something
that's like an antique
you know me and my animals you guys i
love animal figurines and i think
everyone should be surrounded by
animal figures at all times um and uh
and so if someone doesn't rece
it's not really a gift it's homework and
it's and it's
um uh it's a uh forced
my gifts are something you have to enjoy
and use all the time
when we record the podcast at mine i'll
put it right in the middle of the deck
which isn't for you the gift is for me
okay and you need to show everyone i
give you again i want everyone to
compliment the necklace and so you say
whitney gave me this and so that you're
spreading the reputation that i'm a good
person yeah i'm that person who's always
checking in going did you get did you
get it
like did you get because i haven't heard
back from you so i was just wondering if
like
it got lost by the mailman i haven't
seen it on instagram yeah
exactly like this isn't like to tell
everyone about the gift i got you
i need a picture i need a selfie like
there's no point of
my kindness is very conditional and
you now work for me full-time like it is
i know when i like send flowers or
someone i'm like did you get it did you
get it did you get it
yeah i got it thanks yeah yeah
it's the hardest when you try to find
something really rare and specific for
that person it's so personalized
and then they're like yeah thanks i got
it and i'm like what uh
like okay you're not crying yeah yeah
yeah you didn't okay it didn't change
your life
like okay no that's true whatever yeah
it's so
wild how much i need people to receive a
gift the right way
which is by the way my new thing i
remember i was at a um meeting a couple
christmases ago holidays ago um sorry i
know christmas is canceled
um uh and this woman said she goes my
work this year
is to give half as many gifts i gave
last year and every year i'm gonna give
half the amount
and last year my goal was to only give
five people holiday gifts
it was so hard wow it was so
hard and guess what nobody gave a shit
yeah
nobody gave a shit i didn't lose any
friends no one was
mad at me you know and it was um
such a healing experience to not
make my life chaos before the holidays
running around buying people gifts that
they don't need or want
yeah or you know it was like and um it
was all about me
looking generous and trying to make them
like me and whatever yeah i just but i
just also love giving gifts
yeah you know i love receiving gifts so
i'm really happy
like send you a really long message with
loads of emojis like yeah yeah you guys
i love receiving it
um you know that me giving a gift is
about me and not you
uh how do you feel if you make a mistake
i do i do want to say a couple
more things before we um because i know
there's a couple other questions that
i'm skipping
uh how do you feel if you make a mistake
a
i feel guilty and ashamed yes b i have
to tell everyone
c i want to hide it d i reach out to
someone supportive
um i feel guilty and ashamed i feel
guilty and ashamed
first and then i probably do d which is
reach out to someone that
can kind of give me some context like i
like reaching out to someone who i think
holds me in high regard and
sorry not high regard holds me to higher
standards sorry holds me to higher
standards and
will be able to speak about it with me
without judging me because i need to not
judge myself
and sometimes i feel like we need
someone else in our life who doesn't
judge us for a mistake and we go oh okay
i don't have to judge myself and you
might realize you didn't even make one
yeah that's it it might just be your
perfection totally you know reaching out
half the time when i think i've really
fucked up i call someone
supportive and i'm like i did this thing
like so we all do yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly and also nobody cares nobody's
thinking about this
just delete it take it down nobody cares
no one's singing about you yeah you know
it's like uh
my therapist always says she's like um i
have good news and bad news
nobody cares like this huge mistake you
think everyone's obsessing about like
you're not trending who cares
yeah um yeah and and yeah i love that
one and i think it's so important that
people have different people they call
for different things
because the mistake we make again again
the opposite
is that we tell one person everything
yep or we tell everyone everything
and both of those don't work because
that one person gets completely drained
and distanced from us because they can't
deal with that level of overwhelm
and then when you tell everyone
everything we all know what that goes
like yeah so it's so much more important
to be like okay when i have a career
challenge this is the person i go to
when i have this i go to this
and you may say well how do i start it's
important start building those
relationships with people in your life
that
have different skills that they provide
you and you provide something back to
them too
and also don't go to the problem for the
solution and i think
i tend to translate that with
i need to be honest and authentic so
sometimes we conflate over
sharing with i'm going to be authentic
and i'm going to set a boundary and i'm
going to tell them how i feel and i'm
going to be honest
that's not always healthy communication
agreed we say restrain a pen and tongue
like
you're like if you're my problem i'm not
going to come to you and expect you to
have the solution
you know so i have a problem with my
family i might go to my friends or my
program or my
you know jay shetty book or whatever it
is or my podcast to get a solution and
then i'll bring that solution to the
relationship
and the solution might be to say fucking
nothing yeah and to have just dealt with
to
forgive or to turn it over or to um
go for a run or take a nap or uh
you know join a 12-step program or
something chances are the person you
have a conflict can't solve the conflict
for you
well said because that's their the issue
in the first place yeah you solve the
conflict with them
not not you solve the conflict with them
they're not they're not going to solve
it for you i think that's what i said
and if you are going to come to them at
least know what you're coming with and
know what you
want from them and if you're ready if
you're going to come to them with an
ultimatum
be ready to carry it out don't come with
threats and
um know what you want so that you can
know if you're getting it or not yeah
you know what i mean that's the other
thing sometimes we go to people with a
like
you hurt my feelings and then like do
you want an apology do you want to
promise that it's never going to happen
again do you want them to understand
and what's going to happen when they
don't validate your reality yeah then
what's your plan
one of my favorite tools in the
relationships chapter is something that
we had to do a lot of
as monks where you're very careful about
the words you use because you realize
how much
power each word has and so there's a
great
study by harvard which you can type in
on google it's called the list of
emotions
and i often refer to as emotional
vocabulary so all of us have a very
limited emotional vocabulary we
literally use five words
okay good bad fine hmm right so it's
like how's your week going okay how's
your day been good
how's your project going fine right like
that's literally what we say
we in 12-step programs we is it
off-limits word
stands for fucked up insecure neurotic
and emotional
nothing nothing nothing yes and so this
list of emotions by harvard
goes through each key word that we say
most often
and breaks it down into like seven other
words that actually define what it means
so when you say you're sad
are you actually offended are you
irritated are you upset and it gives you
all of these synonyms
but it's helping you diagnose and
articulate how you actually feel so when
you do approach someone
you're actually coming from a place of
giving them clarity because half the
time you diagnose yourself wrong it's
like you see a little rash and you're
trying to diagnose yourself on google
and you've got to
see it yeah and you get it all wrong so
it's the same thing so it's so important
to use words where you've got really
close to what you actually feel
that's the only way someone can actually
it's not the other person's
job to decipher it it's your job to be
clear it's
your job to say it right it's not their
job to be psychic and figure it out so
it took me a really long time at 38
years old it took me a really long time
to incorporate the word frustrated
i'm frustrated about this do you know
what i mean like i'm just
i'm restless i'm irritable i'm just like
that was a big one and we talk about
this a lot on the podcast and halting if
you're hungry angry lonely or tired
you have you you have to solve those on
your own before you engage in halt
i really like that like if i have a
problem with you before i even bring it
to you i have to
am i hungry am i angry am i lonely am i
tired though
i love that before i even start a
conversation with you i need a snack
because half of the conflicts i am in i
just mommy needed a bagel
yeah and like like half of my problems
go away when i just like take a nap and
i'm like oh i wasn't mad at you i just
was i was sleepy you know so it's also
making sure we take care of our most
carnal impulses before we decide to even
honor
those feelings and figure out what they
are but it took me a long time
yeah it's not like i'm mad at you i'm
sad it's like i'm frustrated
i'm disorganized i'm listless
i'm confused that was also a big one
yeah you know for me
uh confused and jealous i used to
conflate a lot
um angry and disappointed i used to
um and everything for me is scared yeah
i've also realized i'm jealous i'm angry
i'm scared
i'm just scared i'm scared of losing you
i'm scared of you not liking me i'm
scared of you leaving it's all fear of
abandonment
so it took me a long time to realize
that that was pretty much everything
yeah
breaking those words is so important so
important
um and you're an adult it's your
responsibility to use the right words
when you're in a conflict
and the positive words too like it's
it's defining also like for example when
someone says
i love you they might mean i want to
spend the night with you
and someone says i love you and they're
like i want to spend my life with you
those are two very different
and so when you hear the word love
you're projecting your belief
of the definition of the word love on to
that person saying it and you go i love
you too
and and you've just not agreed on the
definition of that right and you've just
projected your definition on what you
said and they said and you said that it
met in your head
yes because your word definition was off
and i know that sounds crazy because
when someone says i love you you're not
gonna be like well let's define what you
mean
i in my second special i don't know how
do you want comments it was on comedy
sounds i don't know where the fuck it is
but yeah i did a whole bit on uh
i love you and what it means oh i love
it we have to agree on a common
definition of love and i think
my definition of love is being willing
to die for someone that you yourself
want to kill
i think that's what it was but also a
lot of times i love you means shut up
like i love you
i love you i mean we use it to
manipulate we use it to tell someone to
calm down i love you baby i love you
okay i love you like we use it a lot
it's thrown around a lot yeah
you know you've totally destroyed i need
to watch that that no yeah if you can
find it good luck
um what do you do when you have to make
a big decision a i reflect privately
b i ask my mentors and guides c i weigh
the pros and cons d
i talk to family and friends what do i
do when i have to make a big
decision i take a sleeping pill
i do sleep i it really takes me a long
time
sleep's great i'm really bad at making
big decisions i get very overwhelmed but
i
usually think if if if
if the answer if it's not a hell yes
it's no like it's the answer is usually
no
for any decision for me um it's usually
but it also depends on who if it's an
authority figure i have to tell
i'll sort of get scared that they're
going to be mad at me and i have to sort
of work through that
and then i'll ask mentors and guides
what do you think i should do i'll
outsource the decision to someone that's
not emotional because i get too
emotional
interesting i go private mine's the
first one i reflect privately
yeah i need to like i found that getting
away from noise
and everyone's opinions and expectations
and messages
because then that starts messing with
how i feel and now what i feel is made
up of everyone else's feelings
yes and i don't like that and then
you've recruited a bunch of people and
now they're invested in you
executing what their advice correct and
so i don't enjoy that at all
and so i'm like i want to take all the
my own responsibility but that requires
me to get away
and make my mind up about something and
then i come back with my version and
then i'll check in with mentors and
guides because sometimes when you ask
too many people and they give you their
advice you're like well i don't want to
not take their advice
yeah yeah now you're like i can't
message them again because i'm taking
their advice and they're gonna like
judge me
guys i spent an hour of your time and
i'm not even taking it totally
and that that's my worst nightmare so i
was like no definitely oh that's
interesting okay last one which best
describes your daily routine a it
changes moment to moment
b it's very focused and organized see i
follow the best opportunity that comes
up
d it's simple and scheduled
i mean you're a d you're at simple in
schedule
that's the healthiest i would say i
uh i'm gonna be honest i wish it was
simple in schedule but i do think it
changes moment to moment because i'm so
easily distracted and i can never figure
out how to use fucking dropbox so i
spend
i think my day is scheduled and then i
spend half of it trying to download a
fucking video
yeah um and then i'm like i need to fire
everyone
um it's very yeah i think it's it
changes moment to moment and i
i would like to work on that because i'm
delusional
i tell myself it's simple and scheduled
but it's not yeah
but that's great so you accept and then
you go okay this is what i want let's
pave away
rather than being like oh yeah it's
simple it's scheduled i know how like
people tell themselves things to try to
convince themselves like
when people go look i'm not crazy you're
like that's literally
what a crazy person says to try to prove
to themselves that they're not crazy
and you just made me realize that i say
things about myself like well i'm just
so organized and like i just have my
shit together and like i run a tight
ship and it's like
i'm i say that but it's not necessarily
true it's called uh in steve jobs book
walter isaacson calls it reality
distortion
field and so you have the ability to
distort reality
based on how you want to see it and so
it can get as extreme as when
it said that when steve jobs denied
having a child for example it was
referred to as that
uh in the book at least and so that
that's how far it can go
where if you want to remove something
out of your
memory or life then you you just block
it out i do it with money too oh i think
we all do
like we all have it to some degree we
all practice it all the time and
i think having people who can catch you
on those blind spots or doing activities
and exercises that make you aware of
those blind spots is useful
it's like people who are like i hate
drama and you're like you love drama
oh my god you're obsessed with drama you
love it like
that type of shit well attachment and a
version in the bhagavad-gita it says are
two sides of the same coin
so when you say i love something or i
hate something it's the same
same level of attachment so in the sense
of like we were always trained as monks
they're like
being a monk and and a lot of people get
it wrong and obviously there are female
monks too but a lot of people think oh
if you're monks then maybe you just
don't want to be with women or you don't
like women
actually that cannot be a reason for
being a monk you can't
dislike women to be a monk like hate or
lust are almost two sides of the same
coin yeah where it's still that you're
still completely wrapped up in it
because that's still all you think about
you know what's so interesting i i'm oh
wait let's say wait
don't i don't don't forget that because
i want to come back to that but we
should finish what
let's see what shit i can't even go
through hold on no i know i don't know
how we did that wait hold on i had it
your dog-eared okay what did we get what
did it what did i win what do i win for
being successful i don't know we need to
count
answer key uh tally your answers now the
most selected
letter reflects your varna yeah so which
one's you're gonna have to go through
each of these
oh shit now i have to be good at math
what a nightmare i know i went through
i think i was a cr maker d yeah
make it would make sense to do with what
you do i think i was a maker so you can
be a guide a leader creator maker can
you just tell me
what those mean real quick yeah so a
guide is someone that
is who absolutely loves dealing in
thought ideas
thinkers ideators people who are always
like basically
on a very intellectual and mental level
leaders are people who are always
considering
others wanting to protect wanting to
provide a good president would be a
leader
in in terms of a personality trait they
have the ability to think beyond
themselves
uh creators are people who just want to
build grow
make great entrepreneurs makers are
talented people artists
people who perform people who uh also
work great with their hands they may
even do arts and crafts people are
fantastic at
invention uh so those are very quick
versions of what they are and there's
deep ones in the book
i love this i think you should i think
this is something you should do like
every
like couple months do you know what i
mean too yeah see how you evolve
that's the other thing because it's like
i think i'm big on growing and changing
and like
changing your mind and changing your
opinions and you know i think there's
this like
um thing now where people like i'm this
type of person it's like why would you
want to stay
that way you know why would you want to
get new information
and keep your former opinion it's
actually exhausting to try and stay the
same
because you're just constantly like
trying to hold on to something that's
trying to change
and and that's why i mean you know for
me that the whole point of thinking like
a monk is actually the biggest curveball
in your life because
becoming a monk is actually the greatest
act of rebellion it's the most random
thing you could potentially do
in society it's it's off the wall and so
it's like all of us
need a bit of that off the wall thinking
in our life because that's kind of what
brings you back to balance of where you
are so you have to go become a monk but
what's the most off the wall thing you
can do and i don't mean crazy or
oh it can be curious it can be whatever
you want it to be but you just need a
bit of that
allowing that inner rebel that inner
loud child to
have a moment i want to talk about this
thing real quick about
hate you know that hate and love are so
similar so i had this
um attachment and detachment like
attachment and hate like attack
i wouldn't say love in its pure form i'd
say love and it's attachment
lust codependency coming back and it's
codependency
when we you know it's it i've had this
thing happen where
you know um a lot of people that i had
just inner conflict with i've had on the
podcast recently and i've been like
i used to we used to not like each other
right and they're like what and i'm like
oh i like and they're like han i'm like
i totally made this up in my head i was
projecting all over you
to recreate some childhood circumstances
or something but
i had this you know i hate the word
stalker it's such a weird
word i'm sure you get all sorts of weird
shit now but you know i had this
person that was like reaching out to me
and calling me constantly and would show
up at my house and all this stuff
and um and then we started looking into
him and i had to talk to him on the
phone and you know basically they were
like if you talk to him it'll break the
spell and he'll stop
stalking you which is like actually
really rude when you think about it
like just have him talk to you he'll
leave you he'll you'll scare him away
oh that's what it is sort of like trust
us like just if he talks to you for 20
minutes he'll get annoyed and move on
but it's sure enough it happened and
sometimes people just get obsessed with
someone and then
it's about the chase for them and it's
some kind of psychological thing that
i hopefully will never relate to but i
started getting information about him
and i started looking him up and i
started figuring out where he was and i
started following him and i started and
i realized that i was so much more
obsessed with him than he ever was
with me wow i started stalking my
stalker and i
and i still and i'm like why isn't he
still following me and why is he in
chicago and what is he doing over like
and it was this weird thing where i just
realized like how much
uh uh you know and i don't hate him
but how much are negative feelings about
people
um i love him
i'm in love with him i mean that's what
i realized yeah in a perverted way
yes i was like i hate this guy and i'm
like no i'm obsessed with you i love you
and it just made me realize like how
close those wires
are totally totally and
when i you know it's great you when you
hate someone or dislike someone you're
drinking poison and waiting for the
other person to die is what we say
right so it's just sort of um it just
you really made me think about that
and and just about our
you know how nervousness and anxiety are
so close to each other excitement and
nervousness are so close to each other
totally
and if we can spot that and be aware of
that
and then go actually what i'm feeling is
excitement as well
there is nervousness it just changes it
and this whole idea of
changing how you see things i think it's
a wayne dyer said that
when you change the way you look at
things the things you look at change
and it's a really beautiful statement
and you'll fucking find what you're
looking for yeah
if you go through his phone you're gonna
find something
because you're looking for it it's a
confirmation bias back
yeah can you say that one more time yeah
wayne dyer said uh when you change the
way when we change the way we look at
things
the things we look at change and and the
best example i can give from because i
was like okay let me
let me try and find science on that
because i i love finding like
i love that everything you talk about is
based in actual science yes
thank you yeah no that's a big part of
for me like that's huge for me
and and it's it's what i loved about
monks brains and all the scans amongst
brains show that this is all true
there's all these like people on
instagram they're like if you do this
then you'll
like find the man of your dreams if you
just meditate with this monsters like
where's the science like it says who
yeah weren't you an actress on the cw
like where what
what with what did phd are you giving me
this advice yeah and i don't have a phd
but i quote a lot and i have a lot of
phd friends who are way smarter than me
you connect with us
actually like there's like studies that
back all this up which is because to me
i always need to know why something is
true or else i just can't
my brain can't understand it so i just i
love that it's like
science nerd shit yeah so this this one
you like then so amy rosnewski
at the yale school of management she
looked into they
they said let's find what we think is
the hardest job in the world like the
toughest job
and they think they they think they
found it which was like hospital
cleaners
so people have to clean up after people
pass away clean up after people have
used the bathroom
just you know they felt that was
probably one of the toughest careers on
the planet
and so they went and interviewed them
and they asked them to describe what
they did and a lot of them said we do
low skilled work
we clean we take care of the the worst
stuff inside like all the stuff you'd
expect they described the job
description
and then they asked some other hospital
cleaners who do the identical job
and they described themselves as
supporters healers
transformers uh connected to the
community of the patient
the family healers like they saw
themselves as someone completely
different
and those people were happy at work and
so amy vrznewski and her team named this
job crafting where how when you when
dies quote when you change the way you
look at things the things you look at
change
because they saw themselves being
connected to the patient's healing
being connected to their family being
connected to the work because they
thought about it differently
they got a new human experience from it
which by the way that is so touching to
me it's like i've
with you know having had two parents
have strokes and be in the icu like
those are the heroes like that like the
person
that came in and dealt with that was the
reason i was able to be with my dad
before he died
you know what i mean it's that's how i
see those people that's so
interesting like the second you find
yourself minimizing what you do
you know um look at it from that
perspective like i
i remember when my parents had strokes i
was like well i'm just fucking in tv and
i've
you know we're always in like we're not
curing cancer we're not right we just
tell dick jokes and i'm a comedian and
like
and i was just like being so hard on
myself with my career choice and i just
like make television and like this is
dumb and why aren't i doing something
good for the world and why aren't i
you know um giving back more or
something and then i went
into the icu i was there for a couple
months with
my mom and i you go around and
everyone's watching friends and cheers
and
reba and everyone's just watching tv
shows you know
and you're like oh okay i get to do that
thing
everyone everything that everyone does
can be used in service
everything can be used in service of
others if it was made from a heart of
wanting to help people in whatever their
challenge was
whether you're making tv or whether you
are you know
serving a meal at a restaurant or
whatever you're doing it's it's serving
someone
and and i think we forget that we start
thinking that service is only
this this and this what are you gonna do
what's next well we've got this cult
that i'm working on with
i'm telling you this cult is going to be
so lucrative like i
am cannot wait cannot wait
we haven't got a name yet but yeah i've
been told i have to work on that thing
so yeah doing that
you're doing a cult full time yeah and
then so
how is all this hollywood shit been for
you it's a lot
yeah it's you know what it's been really
it's a good question it's been really
interesting for me
because i didn't it's really i was born
and raised in london
and then i lived in new york for two
years when i first moved to the states
and then i moved here two years ago
and i've i've yeah that's that's how
long i've been here and and i've just
built some really
wonderful deeper relationships with a
lot of
great people and and i think because of
what i do it kind of
turns away people who aren't into that
kind of stuff and so
so it's almost like the people that have
that i have become friends with are all
people who want to
meditate or want to improve their lives
or want to do that and so it's fun for
me
sometimes it's scary i mean i get it
took me a long time to
want to look at myself you know it's
scary but no i was asking because i was
just looking at all your appearances and
you've been like on so many tv shows and
stuff and there was one that really
you probably didn't even notice this was
happening i just need to fucking roast
whoever this person was you were on some
like morning news
show and um i don't i don't even know
who the news anchor was
but he kind of tried this is you're so
successful now you're gonna start
getting people jealous of you and you
know that kind of shit and
gonna trigger people i'm sure but this
guy like tried to be like you know i
know you guys have seen him on social
media he's a big social media star
but his message is about meditation and
this and this and i was like
what are you trying to say like he was
trying to point out some kind of irony
between being big on social media and
that it might
go against anything you say i'm like
bitch how else are you gonna spread your
message like that
it's such a boomer thing to think that
it's anathema to be famous on social
media
and a powerful healer or philosopher
thank you that's very kind and
and and my honest answer to that is no
one mainstream would listen to me or
give me an opportunity so i had to use
social media
so it wasn't even like it wasn't even
like i was like i'm gonna go get
loads of followers on your morning show
fuckheads i had to get 10 million
followers in order for you to have me on
that literally was the truth that i
i i've been talking about this stuff for
15 years since i started getting into it
and i've done this offline for longer
than i have offline so i online so
i did this for 10 years offline uh
just i would speak at events where five
ten people turn up in london for years
and i'm it wasn't about money it wasn't
my followers i didn't i just wanted to
do this because i love what i
have and in the last four years since i
took it online it's turned into this big
thing
but for me it's like that wasn't the
point the point was just i was pitching
my idea
to like tv companies and entertainment
companies and media companies in london
saying
we need more wellness on tv we need more
mindfulness no we need the kardashians
yeah and they
and no one would give me a chance and so
i literally and long story short after
literally a ton of rejections i ended up
at a tv training day for ethnic
minorities
run by the bbc at pinewood studios in in
england
and i go to the studio and there's like
six brown and black people in the room
and we're being trained in presenting
and i went there to check whether i even
had any skills to be in media to share
the message
and at the end of it they're like hey
you've got some good skills and i was
like great give me a job and they're
like there's no jobs in media and i was
like
you brought me here to tell me there's
no jobs in media and then they're like
well you should start a youtube channel
and so me starting on social media
wasn't even a conscious
intentional thing and actually i had
massive limiting beliefs about it
my response to them was well that works
for justin bieber right that doesn't
work for me
and no one's gonna care and then i'd run
out and then at the time
youtube and social media was more of a
cesspool of mental illness
not wellness correct you know what i
mean it was like the internet was like
for porn
yeah it was it wasn't like the stuff
that was going viral or was working
wasn't necessarily
uh positive and yeah and so for me it
was
never about it was just like i just had
to find a way
like that's i was like i have to find a
way and this is the only way that works
for me
so it's it's not selected so negative
about social media like it's like
you know it's it's what's so wrong with
being
the healthy warm respite between private
jet photos
and ass selfies you know what i mean
it's like it's amazing
you know what you're doing and i think
that you know so many people
have gotten you know free mental wealth
from social media like there's this
like trend in podcasting and celebrities
where they want to talk about therapy
i'm like bitch most people can't afford
therapy
even if they can they don't have time do
i mean like therapy is such
an elitist luxury and that's why i talk
about 12-step programs so much because
it is free
you can get it on zoom you can get it on
that's amazing you know so it's like
this whole therapy and a lot of therapy
by the way
doesn't work a lot of therapy is it's
not the right match a lot of therapy is
um uh talk therapy which actually just
re-embeds your traumas and re-uh
it capitulates your story and
crystallizes this
wrong story and a lot of therapists are
invested in keeping you there and they
don't do
apply tools like emdr and hypnosis and
um tools like what we just did that quiz
so
um so i just love that what you do is
available to
everybody at their convenience and um
they can share it with their friends and
totally i love you you're extremely kind
i'm so grateful
honestly well you are well you are to me
sir
no i i'm grateful like to hear that it
means a lot because
i'm also just you know when i became a
monk i followed my heart when i left
being a monk i followed my heart
when i started this i followed my heart
and so i'm just following my heart and
that's looked like lots of different
things yeah
and i've accepted all of those i i get
that there's paradoxes in how i live and
think
but i love that like that's what that's
hopes that's the fun of it like
i don't think anyone is just one thing
and none of us are just one thing and i
think when you
lean into the paradox and go yeah i love
both of these things equally
but also there's no this is what it
bothered me yeah the guy was trying to
make a point that it was a paradox that
you
are um you and you think like a monk
on social media that's not a paradox
dickhead
that it it depends on who you follow so
if you're only following
like fox news and like q and on and
conspiracy theory stuff like yes your
feet is gonna be a little wonky but like
that's not my feed yeah like like that's
not a paradox to me to me it's actually
the most aligned uh with what
you're saying for it to be available to
everybody
and democratic um and uh
yeah i just thought i just i was just
like it's like bother it's just like
watching some of your interviews it's
funny to watch
people i get it but do not think like a
monk come in a month
it's so funny to watch i just i just
give really honest
answers because i i don't have anything
else to give and and i think
it was me i'd be like what are you
trying to say like i literally would
have been like what are you trying to
make a point that why are you trying to
come for social media
boomer and you were just like anyway so
this is what i do like it was just it's
so funny
yeah to watch a healthy person talk to a
not healthy person not at all it is
definitely been
a next level elevation in having to
think like a monk like
the the challenge that i the challenges
that i come across
have made me believe deeper in all these
practices and practice them more deeply
yes because i i can get shaken
immediately and those being attacked or
being like
questioned or all that kind of stuff is
like when you're coming from a good
place
you can sometimes be naive and sometimes
people are triggering to
to you know as we say in program when
when you get healthy the sick get angry
wow it is triggering this 12-step
program i'm telling you i've heard about
a lot from russell too russell brand
who's yeah i've known for a long time
and he talks about it very highly and
and phenomenally and hearing you today
it's just i mean it sounds like the best
program everyone should take it's free
magic weather
yeah it's amazing and i recommend it it
goes so hand in hand with this i think
there's a lot of stuff in your book that
i
would have you know because before
program i was such a black and white
thinker
and i think that buff i think that your
work would have
thrown me a little bit had i not already
been in program i would have just been
like well
i would have gotten too perfectionistic
about it and i wouldn't able to say
i have all of these things in me i
didn't think that many things could be
true at once yeah
you know and i was such a control addict
because what i meant al anon is
an addiction to control perfectionism
martyring uh
you know you have an overdeveloped sense
of responsibility and um
your relationships are you know you
shape-shift in relationships and don't
have an identity
like it's it was sort of perfect prep
you know certainly for getting the most
out of your book and by the way 12-step
programs
you don't have to be in it for every day
it you can pop in you can pop out
it's there's there's no i think people
think it's like i'm in a program i have
to be in it forever it's not
that and it's um it's a true miracle
12-step programs i love it true miracle
um
i don't know i have to i have to let you
go you have nine
a hundred other podcasts today no i
don't know easily
easily the hardest person to schedule um
well no i just mean like no no i don't
mean that i just mean you're you're the
man
no no good thing no i this was i mean
this was so much fun like genuinely
we're first of all we're friends now
yeah we're starting a cult together
we're starting a cult
and and no but i mean it like this we
have different work styles but we'll
i was so looking forward to this and i
think the only thing that happened is i
went to iceland in between that that i
think pushed it back
it was amazing for your book for work
yeah no not for the book yeah for work
and uh
it was just i've been looking forward to
this
because i'm a huge fan and edamara
and and i i watch you all the time and
think you're hilarious and when i saw
that you liked my work
i was like what i was so like i was so
like when it comes to like
work like i was i just never imagined
that you would even care what i did
and so so then i was just like oh this
is so cool and
the way this conversation is going has
shown me exactly why like
i i really love how you went about this
and it excites me so much that i got to
share what i do in a way that hopefully
connects and resonates with everyone you
connect and resonate with
and and more importantly that we've
built a relationship through it so
for me i was in when i when i saw you
were looking at my work and stuff
because i've been just
everyone and and you're friends with
everyone else that i follow in love and
and i was just like no way like and so
anyway i was very uh
i was very humbled and taken aback when
when you took an interesting universe
has conspired
uh to bring us together yeah and um yeah
it's
funny like uh i just my goal today was
like
for you to not have to regurgitate the
same thing you've been saying i know
what it's like to be promoting something
and you're just like
we assume that if someone goes likes you
on something they're gonna go watching
on something else
and then they have to see you say the
same thing you just fucking said and
then you're like ah
like i hate going to interviews where
i'm like i'm i've already told the story
i just said this on something else so if
someone loves what you do they're gonna
watch
all of your appearances and my goal was
to
be able to maybe do something this was
the most unique
interview style and doing that that was
genius and i'm glad
because i literally i don't think i said
anything in this interview that i've
said anywhere else like
i'm so glad yeah i i i love that too
like i think i'm the same that and when
you come back on it's going to be the
same thing i'm hoping that
we can go somewhere that you don't get
to go and so please that's when i go to
pockets and i'm sorry how did you get
into comedy i'm like
there this is you can find the answer to
that on google
i've answered that it's hard to be a
woman in comedy i've answered that
already like someone can find that now
i'm a hack that's repeating myself
and people think that i'm a broken
record and now what don't make me be
annoying yeah
you're making me be the worst totally
don't make me be boring
to the fans like please ask me another
question and literally anything except
is it hard to be a woman in comedy
um okay i'm doing your podcast soon tell
us about the podcast
find it everywhere listen to his podcast
when when when he comes on yeah yeah
only that one yeah
only that one think like a monk anything
else you want
i end these very awkwardly perfect don't
ride elephants don't ride dolphins
[Music]
[Applause]